this is Jocko podcast number 382 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko willink good
evening Echo good evening
the Congo's recent independence from
Belgium had trigger triggered a
secession crisis by one of the country's
most mineral rich and wealthy provinces
it led to an opening for the Soviet Bloc
to exploit rebellions among local tribal
factions
the U.S saw the country as a strategic
geopolitical necessity against communism
which meant the Congo was turning into a
superpower Battleground
the U.S feared that losing influence in
the Congo was the next step to losing
Africa
the CIA had sent me to the Congo to
conduct a clandestine operation under as
deep a cover as possible while still
enabling and sustaining the conduct for
a successful mission
the suits in Washington recognize that
the communist rebels needed to be
contained
the strategy was to cut off their supply
lines and strangle their resource base
which would require battle tested and
seaworthy hands
and the world could not know we were
responsible
we were holding back the line on
Insurgent violent communism
it was the boiling years of the Cold War
and Africa was becoming a hotbed of
potential dominoes that might fall the
wrong way if we didn't pay attention
and as all eyes were focused on that
other communist Battleground in
Southeast Asia
the U.S government wanted to keep Africa
involvement as quiet as possible and
ensure that no one could find our
fingerprints on this up
consequently one of the most important
elements in my Congo mission was to
cover the ass of the U.S government
they needed a guy who had the knowledge
and covert experience to make this a
successful play
the CIA had determined that I was that
guy
right there is an excerpt
from a book which is called Cold War
Navy SEAL it's written by James Jim Haas
Who as a 26 year old seal Lieutenant
ended up building and commanding a small
Navy in the Congo a small Navy that
helped defeat communism in that country
including the Communist icon Shea
Guevara
but it's not all he did in his career
he served with the U.S surface Navy was
involved in the Gulf of Tonkin incident
worked with SOG in Vietnam and has
worked and lived around the world and
it's an honor to have him with us here
tonight to share his experiences and
Lessons Learned Jim
thanks for joining us thank you it's a
pleasure to be here it's always fun to
talk to Young seals who are interested
in ancient history
well it's very it's always nice to be
called the Young seal when I've been
retired for 10 years and I'm 51 years
old so I appreciate it but I guess
everything is perspective right I trade
you
no doubt I always look at the younger
guys I trade with them in a heartbeat
um yeah thanks for coming down and I
guess this is a lot of stuff to cover
let's jump into it um let's just talk
about you know you growing up so you
were born in Oklahoma but you didn't
grow up there right Oklahoma then the
Panhandle to Texas during the second
world war my dad was a Pacific uh
Battleship sailor so what what year were
you born 39 okay and so do you remember
what do you remember about the second
world war if anything
oh well I remember my General
MacArthur's uniform I remember my father
sending me
um
a a bracelet made out of plexiglass from
a Japanese Kamikaze that hit their ship
he was he was in damage control
I remember the first time I saw him
which was after he had been away for
three years
and I of course I didn't know what he
looked like all I knew was there was
that guy standing there in a sailor
uniform and he had to be the guy and I
set the world record in
broad jump leaping into his arms I
remember that very well yeah so and then
of course I remember the end and all the
victory what year did he come home he
came home in 46.
and what year did he leave
of 42. so you just didn't remember the
beginning and then you're growing up
you're listening to the news or I guess
reading newspapers or is your mom
telling you what's going on well
yeah whatever I knew I knew from my
mother right and of course the only you
would do you had some radio
but uh mostly it was it was from um yeah
and this was while you were in Texas
this is why we were in the panhandle of
Texas yeah I am Amarillo my mother was
the classic uh
World War II uh what they call them um
the uh the Riveter yeah except her
Riveter was uh was in a synthetic rubber
plant in uh outside of Borger Texas
and uh because it's had taken all the
had taken all the rubber in the world so
Phillips 66 built it uh built this
butadiene plant synthetic rubber plant
and every morning we get picked up on a
bus uh and Borger and I'd get dropped
off at what today would you call a
daycare center
and she would go make synthetic rubber
to pick me up and we'd go home that was
so it is and uh my first year grade
school you know they weren't building
classrooms they weren't building houses
so we didn't live great
55 years later
I got to say this without choking up 55
years later she apologized to me for the
way we had to live
it during this time because it wasn't it
wasn't good
but of course I didn't notice it you
know it's with my mother and that's the
way kids are and as long as we were
together it didn't we didn't pay any
attention to anything else but it had
bothered her all those years sure
amazing anyway
um yeah so uh how was your dad when he
came home
how is his hearing I always think about
those World War II guys with the guns
firing and they didn't know about it I
mean 16 inch guns on that ship and
damage control he didn't talk about it
once except one time after one of those
kamikazes
uh he said there were 23 guys in uh
damage control and 21 got wounded he was
one that did one of the two he didn't he
never really talked much about it and of
course
in retrospect I didn't ask all the
things I should have and could have
asked
uh but you know I I never
he was fine he was like all his guns he
was ready to get back at it and you know
be with his family and support his
family whatever and what do you end up
doing for a living when he got back well
he did a lot of things he
he he got a he got a job in Wisconsin
when he got back and uh so we
got on a train and and uh went to
Wisconsin to join him a little town
called Beaver Dam population 10 000.
and he worked for the local lumber
company and he ran this cement block
plant
and he was involved in home building
and he was always he was always in sales
type stuff he had quite an outgoing
personality
and uh
yeah so we were there for the next
10 years or so and uh I went to a
there's a local private school called
Wayland Academy which is the oldest
co-educational private school in the
country
and I got a scholarship there which
changed my life because
Beaver Dam wasn't exactly the launching
pad for colleges and universities around
the area
and uh in my head the Headmaster was a
guy named Ray Patterson who was the guy
who built the
Milwaukee Bucks and the Houston Rockets
and he was a hell of a guy he'd been an
All-American basketball player at the
University of Wisconsin in the early 40s
had a huge influence on my life and so
it was a great man
so that was uh that was luck and then
that was all luck and then we uh we
moved back to Texas when I was uh going
into my senior year to what year is the
high school I'd be 56.
so you're just growing up in the like
one of the most iconic periods in
American history no question about it
and did you I mean everything is
everything everything was possible
everything was possible and of course
that's the way my parents were you can
do anything you want to do go get them
you know so were you playing sports in
high school oh yeah what'd you play yeah
I played football basketball track and
Tennis yeah
and the music I mean you got Elvis like
it's just an iconic time is that I
remember when Elvis was on First on uh
Ed Sullivan's TV show yeah that was a
big deal I think that was in 56. maybe
it was spring of 57 I can't remember but
anyway yeah yeah so you're at this time
are you thinking as you're growing up
are you thinking about joining the
military well everybody did you know
everybody had a had a re had a service
requirement
so I I just thought you always assume
that that's that you would do that and I
I
having seen uh
having seen Woodmark Richard rigmark and
the Frogman like so many of the other
guys I said that's for me and
um but I always knew I had these
terrible eyes so I had to
but I also knew someone was going to do
it I you know just never it was never
any doubt in my mind but you end up
going to college right after high school
yeah and then what was the college
experience again you're you're like in
the most Prime oh the word the worst
four years of my life
where's four years of my life I had no
fun I had no money I had no fun I wasn't
I didn't know what I wanted to do except
get out and go to OCS I you know that
was a four years wasted time and I
should have gone into the military right
out of high school and then gone back to
college but I would I but I make I've
made that recommendation to a lot of
kids over the years yeah you know when
you're 18 years old you're not ready to
go college you want four more years of
sitting in a classroom yeah yeah so no
that was well I was so good that I
started I've spent my first four weeks
of college at the University of Texas
had a girlfriend in Wisconsin
I was a walk-on at Daryl Royal's first
year at the University of Texas and you
know he was a icon coach football coach
in Texas and I guess around the world
around the country and um so you know
Dale Royal in his first year when Texas
was coming off the floor wasn't
interested in 155 I mean 155 pound
quarterback who couldn't see and plus I
had this girlfriend in Wisconsin so I
came home from my first weekend in
college my mother's all excited I first
got to go to college of course in the
family
and uh
I said well I'm going to Wisconsin
needless to say it caused some hate and
discontent at the table
and uh I'll never my dad took my side
and I remember when he drove me to the
bus station the next morning to get back
to Austin to get
throw my stuff in a box and get on a
train he said I want you to know that's
the first time your mother ever went to
bed mad and woke woke up Matt
so don't screw up well of course I did
but
then I spent that I spent the rest of
that year at a really good place called
Lawrence now called Lawrence University
it was called Lawrence College then
in Appleton Wisconsin and it and then I
was so ashamed of myself by the end of
that year
and I said this is just crazy I'm going
to start all over from forget Sports I
gotta you know I gotta do something
right so I went to I went so I went to
SMU
and and there was a dean there and I'm
Mack Adams
and I said Dean I got no money and I'm
on academic probation
but I said uh that the dean at Lawrence
will give me a recommendation
and helped me get some jobs I like to go
to school here
he said fine
so used to help me get a couple of jobs
and uh and so I finished my next I
basically did four years and three years
at SMU and you just worked hard the
whole time yeah I just worked hard I had
jobs and I you know I had yeah I just
had extra load of classes but it became
a matter of Pride diminish in four years
which is stupid because all I meant was
my great my grades weren't very good
so you can understand when I said to my
son who's now in college son
you can come to me with any problem any
concern you got because you can't make
any mistake that I didn't make
yeah did you so at what point did you
start applying though do you have to did
you have to apply for OCS applied OCS I
did it during my senior year and uh
and so I graduated I think mayor June
and I went to osis I in August what year
was this 1963 1961 1961. so I finished
OCS because of Christmas Etc in February
of 1962. okay and your first job was as
a surface Warfare officer right well
yeah on a floating refrigerator it was
USS Vega AF 59 it was a briefer
and I was the damage control it's a
literal Refrigeration ship that yeah I
did all the undersea replenishment
replenishments a hell of a captain a
really good Captain so that was really
good it was good it was a good
experience I became an odd officer of
the deck underway Etc I mean it's not
exactly like being officer of a deck of
destroyer in formation but it's called
independent steaming
and uh and so yeah so I had
bought myself some contact lenses with
my first paycheck and it was when it was
in OCS so I had my contact lenses your
contact lenses at the time were brand
new technology type thing they weren't
in the forms they didn't have anything
anything about
contact lenses in the Navy forms so
you got a little section in your book
about this and I think I thought was
pretty um
that was pretty good you stay here I
considered applying to become a frog man
and you you said that because you saw
that Frogman movie yeah did your dad
tell anything about Frogman I didn't
even know about it no no no I didn't
tell me anything about it
you say but my eyesight was enough to
keep me out of the seals all together to
enter the Navy and attend officer
candidate school to become an
unrestricted line officer I needed a
medical waiver my eyesight was 2200 the
worst allowable under the required
medical standards if correctable to 2020
with eyeglasses so I purchased contact
lenses with my first Navy paycheck I was
fully aware that my eyesight might
prevent me from even entering the
Frogman training I went to Yakuza yokusa
Naval Base hospital and timed my eye
exam to occur during the Lunch Period
there was a Corman Striker a medic in
training on duty in the unit I knew his
minimal medical experience would yield
the least resistance to my desired
result I said Carmen I need to get back
to the ship can I read the chart to
complete this exam with contact lenses
in I read the chart and passed with
excellent 2015 vision
there's nothing on any of the forms that
question the contact lenses or anything
related since the forms had not kept
pace with the technology my application
sailed through channels and I got
immediate orders to report to underwater
demolition team replacement training
class 29 commencing January 2nd
1963. I was in yeah that was of course
in terrible you know it didn't a
terrible shape because I just got off
the ship and and went East to stop for
Christmas about folks and went East and
um
and you know the the the moral dilemma
that I had was the officers carry their
medical records and I looked in my
medical jacket and I sure as hell there
was my there was my waiver the last page
in the on in the jacket
and so the quality do I did I tear it
out or did I leave it in well you know
you can't you you're on you've got an
oath and so I thought well let's see if
God wants me to be a frogman
little report in over there and they had
a first class diving corpsman not not a
not a frog first class diamond corpsman
on duty and he was receiving the medical
records you use these Squad jumper and
you handed him your medical
jacket and he starts going leafing
through it and he flicks the pages
and the last page with the the waiver on
it stuck to the previous page so he
didn't see it so I thought Whoopi a man
of course then I'm looking at everybody
through my contact lenses
and so we started the training
and we're down to we had gone to uh we
just finished Camp Pickett which was
about halfway through training and so
you're so you're going through what they
used to call UDT replacement training
which is now called Buds and you're
going through class 29 and this is on
the East Coast because for a while they
Rancier training on East Coast and West
Coast you're on the East Coast which is
in Virginia right
and it's January it was the snowiest
winter they had had in recorded history
in Virginia I'm going to tell you
something that you will understand this
I haven't been an instructor
the instructor the the the days leading
up to Hell Week were pretty nice was
pretty nice weather
and the instructors kept saying it
always snows for hell week
we go to bed on on we go to bed on
Sunday evening and the weather's not bad
it you know after midnight at all you
know not all Cuts loose
we fall out of there stumbling all over
ourselves and we fall down in the snow
you can imagine the psychological
impact that had these wow these
instructors have
they do magic
and that was the start that was the
start of it
it was called Jesus and the uh but you
weren't really physically prepared
because you've been on a ship yeah I
knew what did you know about SEAL
training nothing no the movie I didn't
know anything about it except it was
going to hurt a lot
that's all I knew I met some guys at the
Officers Club in in
yokuska who knew something about it and
they were telling me uh we were having
drinks and they were telling me about it
and I thought well it should I guess
this really is gonna hurt
but what do you know what you do is do
what you have to do how long was it
was it like six months long the base the
uh
it will yeah six months long yeah and
was there was there anything that really
challenged you
did you have a hard time like were you
good in the water I was uh was I was
good runner I was good on the obstacle
course
I was good in the water in the pool but
when we got into that into the ocean
with those heavy duck feet on my skinny
little legs and that that was painful I
remember we were in Rosy roads for uh
for for training and we're uh I don't
know I think it's three miles swim or
the five mile swim when you're going
around the island in
I got oh it was a three mile swim I got
more than six feet away from my swim
buddy
so the next one which was I guess five
miles whatever it was a little fuzzy in
the thing but it was a long way uh they
put a three inch Hauser between tied me
to my swim buddy so I was dragging that
we were dragging that thing through the
entire swim I'm crying like a baby in my
face mask I mean it it really hurt
[Laughter]
but it it finished
the pain will eventually stop and of
course when you're swimming around in in
the Tide's going the wrong way all your
members and you try to get into the into
the coral
to break it up but you don't want to get
the coral and get get cut to pieces I
remember stroke stroke and looking up
there was this little house or shut or
something up on this point in the
ceiling we're as close into the coral so
we can get I'm stroking them and that
place is staying exactly in the same
place
we did our we did our five and a half
nautical mile swim just in Coronado just
down and back and I remember you know
you're like looking at whatever some
marker on the beach and it's just not
moved it's just not going anywhere
you're like why is this taking so long
you're thinking the current you're
thinking it's the wind you're thinking
it's your swim buddy it's like no it's
just going to be a long arduous time and
by this time
by this time the instructors found out
that I was going to be coming back to be
their boss
so that that took place because they
found out about your vision yeah so talk
us through that oh yeah so they found
out about my uh so
we finished Camp Pickett we're halfway
through the training and I get called
into the and we're down to the hardcore
it's pretty much the hard course you
know and uh so I get called the
instructor's Hut and the funniest guy
there was in the SEAL Teams economy uh
Escapes Me Now the hell of a guy and he
says Mr oz how many fingers am I holding
up I thought whoa oh
and he said I want to see you back there
in officer's country
if I go back
come to attention
face to face with the guy whose job I'm
subsequent I have
and he says okay oh it's what you do
it's stolen the absolute truth that's
all I could do
he's shaking I'm telling the story he's
shaking his head and I see he said well
do you know you might be eligible for a
court martial I said I don't think so
sir I didn't say anything and I didn't
sign anything
and he said well I don't know what's
going to happen but you got to get over
and get to the Ophthalmology Department
right now and get an exam so I go over
the Ophthalmology Department the doctor
says
well I'm glad to meet you you're a
medical phenomenon you've gone from 2200
to 2015 in less than a year
Bureau medicine wants to know about you
he said well it's exactly the way it is
Doc
and uh and he said well we've got to
give you he I said I got contact lenses
and um he said well okay and he said
well I don't know what I can do about
that and I said well
doc you got to do something that's not
good enough you got to do something you
say well let me give you an exam so he
does the exam and sure enough I'm 2015.
and he said well I don't know what to
say you're 20 you're you're 2200 and I
said doc you got to say something you
just got to say something he said I can
say you're extremely well adapted for
contact lenses so say it so he said it
so I go back to the train and I'm
missing some evolutions of course the
instructors aren't happy about that
and nobody knows what my status is
they're going to be or whatever so
I get called over the senior medical
officer in Atlantic Fleet
and I'd seen this guy watching training
he liked to come come watch during
whatever
so I get called in to see him I
walk in ramrod straight tension 10
Henson laws reporting is directed sir
blah blah blah he just looks at me
and
I I he just looked at me like he was
looking into my soul
and finally I couldn't stand any longer
and I knew this was it this is the
quarter Last Resort
so I just from the tip of my toes
the intensity just came out and I said
Emerald I'm standing first in my class
right now so don't tell me I'm not
physically qualified
and he he just looked he just kept
looking at me and finally said okay I'll
recommend a waiver as far as I know it
hadn't been done before
so I was always grateful to you you got
to see a guy like that'll take a
situation on its merits rather than just
go by the yeah that was that was good
Navy yeah anyway so that wasn't the end
of it though because in those days you
know the Navy wouldn't let the seals do
their own training because you know the
seals were you the frogs were the
Orphans of The Unwanted orphans in the
Navy and um so I get caught and it's so
it's run by the Naval Amphibious school
which is run by a captain for striper so
I get called over to the captain's
office
in a positive and this is a regular
Fleet guy yeah oh yeah so I get uh
Richardson Hall's report he's directed
sir and he said okay what'd you do
so telling the story he's shaking his
head he said well I have
I have a recommendation here for a
waiver that I can afford either approved
or disapproved how would you like to
come back as an instructor I said
Captain I'd love to do that after I've
operated a couple years I'd love to come
back to the structure he said I don't
think he understood me and said
I got a waiver here that I can forward
either approved or disapproved how would
you like to come back as an instructor I
said I love it Kevin
so the the award came down I went to
jump school you don't have to be able to
see the jokes you know and then went to
underwater Swim School and uh
the diving medical officer there wasn't
going to allow me to
to complete the underwater swim school
because I had contact losing since I
said doc I said I'm not trying to hurt
myself or anybody else I went into a
chamber went down to 200 feet with my
contact lenses in it doesn't doesn't
matter
well you're going to do it so I go to
see the XO and the exos the next frog
I said don't worry Jim by the time I
will request a waiver by the time they
act on it to it you'll you'll be
finishing the training so so did you
pretty much wear contact lenses all the
time all the time and they never like
fell out or one did one time and no
Factor no no Factor
actually it was what we were doing
around the world in hell week okay in a
in a branch just picked it right out
just I'm glad they had the lens the
weather's got my eyeball it just picked
it right up but it didn't matter I had
another set so what's around the world
during hell week we had this uh
exercise where we we took the boats we
took through all canals we went through
all kinds of mud flats all kinds of
whatever stuff but around the world he
ended up as I recalled back in the bay
paddling into the yeah whatever but it
took most of the night yeah and Coronado
what they do is they they launch you
into the bay side of the core of
Coronado and you you know you carry the
boats over there go through the mud then
you launch and then you paddle all the
way around Coronado all the way back out
the channel out into the ocean and then
back and you come into the beach but it
takes like like six seven hours
and people are falling asleep and it's
usually pretty late I mean it's maybe
two or three days in a week and it's a
little bit of a it's a little bit like
you get time away from the instructors
you know so you're good so people are
like falling asleep and but yeah it's
just the law I really can't almost can't
remember I mean I can only remember bits
and pieces of it it's like you know your
mind's so far out of gear by this point
you just people are hallucinating and
stuff and seeing stuff and probably not
the best time to lose your contact lens
for oh well uh so so then you come back
so you just graduate from training and
then they send you right as an
instructor yeah so then I have so we're
down in Puerto Rico during the you know
the in doing these long swims and all
that stuff and and uh the instructors
find out of course they always always
find out and um
Master Chief Tom Place who is
one of the old Legends
uh
you said to me Mr Hawes I'm going to
make make it my mission
to make sure you deserve to be my boss
so I had his personal so you're asking
about swimming so I had his personal
attention and in uh in Puerto Rico and
I'd be on those long swims in my
my legs would be like rubber in place
that'd be on my ass
so I got a lot better at it but I was
never really never really one of the top
guys in the water were you were those
UDT guys that were putting you through
training were some of those guys World
War II guys or career guys yeah yeah we
had a guy named John Parish who drove
the uh who drove the uh The Landing
boats at Iwo Jima or North terawa Tarawa
uh we had uh fabulous guy just died a
few years ago named Jim Cook who was a
world two frog
we had a fabric and we had a fabulous
guy
named Chester Cleveland so he was
actually had him later Chester Cleveland
Stevens who had gone to work for the
agency and he was down at a base they
had North Carolina
when I was doing some training for the
agency down there
and uh conducting some training for
these with with Chester and he was one
of the guys whose body they used when
they put together the Navy diving tables
they put him in a chamber and take him
down and his and he met his the woman
who was his wife for 50 years or
whatever she was she was one of the
nurses on the chamber and so they'd take
him down
starts bringing him up if he went he
started he started to go he started to
bend quickly take him back down again oh
Olive guy a hell of a guy what was his
name Chester Cleveland Stevens the the
guy that they based the Navy I don't
know I'm sure they had more than one
yeah but he was that's still crazy yeah
crazy about what else they're gonna do a
trial and error I mean how is she gonna
do it so anyway uh and uh Benny silinski
Chief slinski was our uh was our chief
instructor and he was World War II guy
you know hell of a guy
hello guy yeah all these guys treated me
when I reported into the you know after
training treated me like I'd been their
teammates for 20 years and the best they
ever met I mean it was they were so
professional this is a fabulous year
and then how many classes did you watch
get put through two two what'd you learn
from watching classes get put through
especially because it was so fresh in
your mind I sure learned that you can't
tell anything about anybody that you
can't see inside of
it's a weird thing isn't it yeah and how
to how in in try to get a little better
and how to look inside but it's pretty
hard you gotta you gotta put them under
people under stress of one kind or
another to find out what they're made of
it's very bizarre I I went down right
after a report I went down to Key West
to screen to get to screen people that
were going to apply
I came back and I said yes the
instructors that said well I met the guy
who's going to be honor man this next
class oh yeah
you know that damn guy was the first to
quit not the second the first to quit
well you can imagine
what made you think he was going to be
so awesome he was just really good
physically
uh even after having just gone through
it I I still undervalued the mental you
know toughness it takes I had I had a
friend he was a captain and he was very
very careful and he's never recommended
anybody he would say this he'd say I'll
never recommending anybody and finally
this candidate came along the officer
and he spoke a few different languages
and he had all these assets and went to
some Ivy League school and he would this
this particular Captain was very forward
thinking and like oh we need to start
learning languages and I think he spoke
you know like some crazy combination of
languages like Farsi and Chinese I mean
some really good combination so he
finally breaks down and gets this guy
the gets this guy to go to buds the same
thing I I didn't remember I didn't know
about any of that part I only knew when
the guy quit and I was a I was in the
office when this guy get the word are
you kidding me if I'm never doing this
again I've never recommended anybody
again then
next class we had this officer really
good physically top ivy league
university spoke fluently Spanish and
Portuguese that had everything and the
instructors were saying oh this these
guys Mr Smith's going to be honor man I
said nope I'm telling you this guy has
has imposed his own limitations and when
he hits him he's going to quit
yeah what about so-and-so so we start we
start hell week and on the first day I
ease up to him as we're running on the
beach in the afternoon I said how you
doing Mr Smith
fine instructor said Mr Smith these
instructors think you're going to be
honor man but I think you're going to
quit
and uh never instructor okay well when
you get ready let me know
next Tuesday the next morning on the
next afternoon Tuesday
and it's a beautiful day
I'll say Mr Smith how you doing oh fine
instructor I said you know Mr Smith look
at all those ships exercising out there
in the bay I said all the smart officers
are sitting in the wardrobe drinking
coffee
why are you here oh I couldn't be a frog
instructor okay well I don't think you
are when you're ready let me know
Wednesday
Mr Smith I can see your dragon you sure
you want to put up with this I mean
you're so smart and well educated
whatever you sure you want to do this
yes instructor I said well I don't think
so Mr Smith but when you're ready just
hand me your helmet
Thursday afternoon or Thursday hell week
this is
okay yeah Thursday afternoon I said well
Mr Smith you ready to quit yes
instructor he answered me as hell
okay
yeah how do you know
and we had another guy you probably
heard of him named Randy Wise he was in
all he was a he was jump happy he was a
parachute guy wonderful guy wonderful
guy
and he was in the same class so I
thought well I'll work I always worked
on the officers I didn't you know I
worked hard on the officers and uh so I
went up to Randy on the same Beach same
since everyone know how you doing Mr
wise
oh fine instructor just said uh Mr wise
what makes you think you're going to
complete this training
he said you did instructor
so I left him alone
we became great friends
[Laughter]
now this is what what so are we in 1963
right now we're in 1963 yes so what do
you know about the SEAL Teams versus
going to a UDT team well I just see
these guys in the channel that's all I
don't know don't know much about them
because after I'll remember all they did
basically was take the secondary
missions of the of the udts to make them
the primary Mission and the seals and
everybody was going through the same
training so there was no
you know it was kind of like how do you
go how does how does the Navy get more
Appropriations got it particularly in
the aftermath of the JFK
thing for special Warfare and so forth
and the Navy looked around that's why
Ben Milligan's book is so instructive
you know it's just great fun great work
yeah and uh it's also why I don't
believe there'll ever be a Navy there
will never be another Admiral in charge
of Socom
the regular armies got it
really oh and Socom will be diluted
it'll be the Kent stems it's culturally
they can't stand themselves they have to
they have to be big army big regular
army they can't help it and to some
extent the Navy is that way but less so
thank God otherwise we wouldn't be
around we wouldn't have got to do what
we did but I you know I've
right these the cultures are such that
they can't stand uh oh look at the
following the Marine Corps fought yeah
before they finally
finally came around because they had to
there's too much pressure on yeah
well that'll be interesting it seemed
like they have a little bit of a
rotation going on for the socom
Commander well I think they did uh we'll
see if it continues I'm just skeptical
okay because I you know I've spent all
all I I never got to really work much
with seals I was always kind of a
balloon Ranger
and uh and always we were there and
everything was so politically sensitive
we were always talking to these guys at
headquarters and the guys at
headquarters think they're at
headquarters because they're smarter
than the guys in the field
if you were if you were as smart as I am
you'd be here you wouldn't be in the
field I mean you look at Vietnam with
Lou Corning a guy had worked with Ho Chi
Minh he wouldn't get listened to I
talked to jock Richardson who was chief
of station and during the at the DM coup
I knew him I talked to him he said we
told him
don't get rid of him now we've got
nobody to replace him we can get rid of
them anytime but don't do it now
and of course you know the the the
Glorious Elite uh determined otherwise
and what do we have then for the next
and we were there so would they have
five
five new governments in the next six
months all of which we were there some
of which during the demonstrations were
targeting Us in with the white elephant
in in Da Nang
that was also another lesson that I got
for
for uh
uh agitated for for crowd
manipulation in the in its communist
agitation propaganda Department of how
to control mobs we stood up there on the
third floor there's only three floors in
baghdang after one of these changes the
government and watching the you know
they got in the this crowd of people
whipped up and they were going to come
in and we had everything burned and we
weren't going to fire until they started
coming up you know from the second floor
and we're looking down on this mob and
you see Five Guys
it was right out of the right out of the
manual Five Guys manipulate Layton
manipulating this crowd so if you know
what you're doing it's easy because my
mom's got no mind you're right just need
someone to give push them in the right
direction momentarily and they follow
each other exactly yeah
um so you get so so how long you do two
classes you you're that was an
instructor for two classes are they are
they how many classes they do in a year
at that time like how long does it take
okay so you're there for basically I
wasn't there for the full second class
because uh well they how long was it
until you got orders to UDT 21. oh I
mean of course you know I would go to
work on that immediately so I went over
I wanted to see Ken wolf who was the
lieuten commander in charge of 21 and I
said
I said Mr Wolf you you need operators I
want to operate get me a waiver he said
sure So he separate separate Jeff
separate chain of commands every trouble
so boom he got me uh he got me a set or
his income the orders
phone rings it's captain Lee at the
Naval Amphibious School pause get your
ass over here right
so I wrote everything it's Law's report
he's directed Captain you frogs are
always pulling this crap
we we got a deal you're an instructor
I'm getting these orders canceled right
now which she picked up the phone and
did
four Stripes two and a half stripes
uh
but the waiver was on the books that was
the key the waiver to be an operational
the waiver was on the books and that
paved the way then for uh when Tarbox
called me from seal that paid the way
for when carbox called me from Seal Team
too and said you want to go to Vietnam I
can't tell you what what it is because I
don't know if she asks how soon can you
be ready to go so yeah so you so you
have this waiver in the books which
means despite your eyesight you're going
to be able to go and operate you get the
ant orders get canceled the UDT 21 and
you got a little section about this in
the book you say almost a year later I
received a phone call from Tom Tarbox
Seal Team 2 XO he was calling with the
kind of offer I've been waiting for I
have two questions he said one do you
want to be assigned to Vietnam on a
mission so secret that it comes right
straight out of Secretary of Defense
McNamara's office and two how soon can
you be ready to go I replied yes sir and
24 hours
there were very few officers available
with my experience and Tarbox knew I was
more than ready to join an operating
team
when captain Lee heard about it he was
infuriated with me all over again
thinking I had circumvented him and the
agreement we had made he summoned me to
his office yet again and after venting
his Fury he picked up the phone to get
my orders to Vietnam canceled
a struggle to hold in this surging Joy
as I watched his demeanor turn from
imperius to obedient he finally hung up
and said congratulations Lieutenant JG
Haas whatever it is it's so politically
sensitive it comes straight from
secretary McNamara's office is there
anything I can do to assist you
so I was off to Vietnam reported Seal
Team two the next day and had a cup of
coffee with Tarbox and my life as a
covert operator began
when I went to the 25th reunion which
was not anything fancy like they do
these days of Seal Team too it was in a
it was in a bar in Virginia Beach
and uh you know the name Eagle Gallagher
Bob Gallagher Eagle yeah
Eagle Gallagher walks up to me like he's
about to beat my ass and he said what
are you doing here and I said I'm here
because I belong here and you speak to
Tarbox if you if he got any questions
you got any doubt well of course they
swinged up in a hurry but
it was uh it was I almost had the
shortest tenure in Seal Team too and
anybody in history so
yeah that's uh I like I like uh
captain Lee just happened to go from you
know you're not going to is there
anything I can do to assist well you
know but again that's another good
that's to me that's another Kudo for the
Navy because the guy said okay geez
whatever let me help I squared away yeah
Point yeah uh you say here after
detaching from Seal Team two Bound for
Vietnam I stopped by to visit my parents
and brother by that time I was trained
and fit frog man headed for war in the
pursuit of my dreams as I concluded the
visit with my folks my mother put her
arms around my neck and said Jim take
good care of yourself please tell them
not to send your body home if you get
killed
I could not go through it twice
her words were liberating to me I knew
it was hard for her to let me go but I
also understood and always had that she
wouldn't try to deter me maybe you had
to grow up as she did in the heart of
the Dust Bowl and as a wife of a World
War II sailor on a battleship to be able
to be that strong
it was typical of her to be encouraging
of whatever I wanted to do yet saying
goodbye to me twice once as I departed
for war and then again as a casualty
wasn't something she could do
but there were no guilt trips no whining
she didn't cry she was completely
supportive without a selfish gesture of
any kind her only other request was just
please write
I was ordered immediately to
military assistance command Vietnam
Special Operations group Naval advisory
Detachment based in Danang where I would
spend the next year participating in the
Takeover the cia's operation 34A and its
expansion and intensification under the
Department of Defense
I wrote every week on Sunday night
it's a good sign right there
yeah that's a good that's a good son
right there
I guess people have it easier nowadays
with email oh and uh yeah I think email
was a good thing because
you know if you can call or now nowadays
guys can FaceTime right and you and then
that's cool but it's lost right it's
it's very interesting for me to go back
we didn't have that kind of
communications you could I I I would
call my wife like once a week maybe once
every two weeks
in fact we had uh BTF Tony who was one
of my friends and he remembered he came
into my office and he's looking over my
shoulder I have an email from my wife
that says something like I haven't heard
from you in a month is everything okay
he just looked at me and said what's
wrong with you dude write your wife
uh but um
but I think that's cool because now you
can look back and you say you can read
your old emails you know you can you can
read it like I know what was happening
during deployment I'm looking at what
I'm writing my wife I'm like oh I hope
everything's okay you know and there's a
lot of stuff going on a deployment but
it's interesting to be able to review
that so you know that's a good thing
about writing letters as opposed to just
a phone call
um
so you end up with this uh Mac vsog
in you know you say under this Authority
and McNamara's Direction the military
would take over opplan 34A where a
principal strategy included the
establishment of the naval advisory
Detachment NAD do you call it NAD what
do you call it okay
employing small boats to run harassing
raids against North Vietnamese
installations all 34A maritime
operations were approved by President
Johnson's National Security advisor
uh McGeorge Bundy
and communicated directly to NAD Danang
with a copy to inform Saigon I mean this
is micromanagement at the highest level
oh you can't believe it you go with your
because we go on you'll hear you'll hear
why I made the comment before about
headquarters mortality Jesus yeah well
McNamara was the worst yeah and Johnson
those guys were just absolutely horrible
yeah uh targeting was done in a vault at
Bach done
that means white elephant in Vietnamese
uh where the Intel is secured Ops
planning took place including proficient
aerial photography interpretation by a
Navy Intel Lieutenant who's essential
part of that mix the seals took part in
the planning of the operations and
conducted the training of the raiding
teams which were made up of South
Vietnamese Navy personnel I was assigned
as training officer and assistant
operations officer to help run the
operation
So you you're the only reason the only
way that could happen is that the Navy
had no idea
the Navy was told to send somebody with
these qualifications it wasn't told
about rank no tell about nothing because
I got relieved by uh I was still a JG I
got relieved by a full lieutenant and a
lieutenant commander
same job
so the only only way I got that job was
to Jay is the JG is because the Navy
didn't know what it was all about and
what years is this is now 64. 64. spring
is 64. you show up there
um actually you say this is pretty
interesting since there were no no
precedence no manuals no procedures for
what we were doing the learning curve
was dramatic and we were only limited by
imagination of what we could make work
our group was plausibly deniable
clandestine operation and needed to stay
that way
we had to not only avoid our own media
but the international Control Commission
the ICC a group of three inspectors
representing Canada Poland and India who
were tasked with monitoring aggression
in the region
an important part of my mission was to
avoid the ICC because the North
Vietnamese were protesting our raids and
trying to bring International public
attention to our actions while Secretary
of State Dean Rusk repeatedly and
publicly denied our existence
so what's what's your op Tempo like like
what's going on like what's a day look a
day in the life for lieutenant JG Haas
in this 1964 in Vietnam
um
I was a training officer and the
assistant Ops officer
so with respect to training this this
detachments came out from CLT even one
to actually do the training
uh Irish Flynn you know far first
Admiral was the first to First OIC of
that training Detachment that I met
and he was relieved by Maynard wires you
know I don't you ought to know that guy
and you ought to get him on he's a
stupid invite let's make it happen he's
got history like crazy and he was a hell
of an officer
um
and so they were they were running the
training of our of of our individual
teams and we had as I recall six six
individual teams of of composed of nungs
not not mixed couldn't mix
and and uh and Vietnamese
and they were we were Adam isolated in
camps one one mile apart along China
Beach
so this is the same area that Meyer
later occupied after NAD was gone and
this was all taken over by um
SOG CNC
um and they tell they talk about marble
Mountain yeah marble Mountain was the
southern end of this whole complex
that's where I learned to repel you know
I didn't I picked it where did I learn
to do uh to um free fall uh you know the
Chiefs couple of chiefs got me and got a
helicopter and said okay here's what you
do blah blah blah we got it up that was
in Vietnam Free Fall School in Vietnam
which was just a couple Chiefs which is
on China Beach right
[Laughter]
safety third yeah exactly
and anyway
um
uh so yeah so we had these six six teams
all along here which would then go do
the uh do the raids in the north and I
would if I can remember the op Tempo
correctly because we definitely
accelerated from what it had been it
probably twice a month but not always a
team but always the boats because we got
there the Navy had no small boats I am
not exaggerating no small boats
so the only three boats that we had were
the Swifts
um and they were brought there by the
CIA because they were really good for
they were really good vote
yeah but the CIA mostly was doing junks
they'd get they get fishing junks which
they felt were more
had a less chance of being observed and
so they would modify fishing junks and
send guys and send their teams up before
we we took over and then we had that
then we had the Swifts
and but the the none of this could do
the kind of harassment of the coastal
installations which could be done with
the nasties so to the Navy's credit they
bought the best boats in the world from
the Norwegians which are the nasty PT
boats and they were uh 95 feet long they
made 45 knots you go all full to all
reverse just like that
nape high performance nature Napier
Delta diesel engines that you you
couldn't even be in the engine room they
had such a wine you know whatever
whatever terrific boats
um and so those started going up two or
three times a month and that was those
were the boats that
were causing the uh the irritations to
the I
I don't pretend to be able to say how
valuable what we did really was
and I'm not sure anybody can if they
said they could I'm not sure I would
believe them
we it's reasonable to assume that we
tied up a lot of North Vietnamese assets
because we were painting their butts
how actually destructive we were I'm not
sure a couple of times got really lucky
and did some real real good stuff
one of those was Prior just prior to the
gulf Tonkin incident
and
following up that one that was quite
successful
we uh with the votes went up to do
hanmat and Han May and on new which were
Islands sort of in the roads leading to
the high falling Harbor and of course
High Farm Harbor was sacrosanct
let me tell you how sacrosync they were
that when I arrived into Nang
green Lieutenant JG
and I said okay let's look at the end
let's you know let's read it let's look
at the Intel and so there was two
dredges Porter High Fong if they if
they're out of action the porter High
Fong silts up in six weeks
so well this is easy let's go get the
let's go get the dredges oh no can't
touch the dredges
never touched the dredges the entire War
why is that
well I don't know I think it's criminal
but I don't know why it is because it
was you know it was our I think it had
to do with the
with the the headquarters genius concept
that which McNamara describes himself
later on when he's trying to excuse
Holly did all he did wrong
um by thinking that you know we were we
were going to
increase our pressure incrementally to
the point where Ho Chi Minh would say
Okay ouch
we're done
and so I think part of the incremental
approach was to allow them
to continue to have access
to uh haifung Harbor and we would impose
the the punishment
elsewhere okay I I I I
that's thinking doesn't make any
statologic doesn't make sense to me but
it I can't think of anything any better
yeah uh because that's where all the
Soviet stuff came in a lot of the
Chinese stuff came in it's terrible you
know I I um
so I wrote I wrote a book called
leadership strategy and tactics and in
that book I write about something called
the the iterative decision-making
process meaning hey we take a little
step in this direction and we see what
the results are and if it seems like we
get good results we go a little bit
further in that direction and if we see
more good results we go a little bit
further in that direction if we see oh
that didn't work the way we want it to
we make adjustments and it's the way I
always made decisions you know I always
you know I don't need to I don't need to
make a big giant decision I can make a
little one and I can make a little one
make adjustments and then you know as I
started reading a lot about McNamara
you know you get this idea of this
incremental approach and I started
thinking to myself like hold on well if
I was McNamara
maybe I would have been thinking the
same thing I'm going to make these small
steps why was McNamara's
incremental approach why did it turn out
so bad compared to what I did my whole
career which was this iterative approach
they're basically the same thing and it
didn't take me very long of thinking
about it to realize why
because the key component of me making a
small decision is to pay attention to
the feedback and make adjustments when
it doesn't work
and what you can see with McNamara and
Johnson is that they were getting
feedback and they were just not paying
attention to it they weren't listening
to it they were just saying no but keep
going keep going keep going keep going
and they never paid attention to the
feedback and they continue to take the
same approach over and over again and it
never worked well I couldn't agree more
I think that's astute yeah I couldn't
agree more
they'd understand will they'd understand
the will and these guys are such
compromisers they just didn't understand
this they will yeah and you know I think
we're seeing that you know people ask me
about the warno in Ukraine right now and
it's a test of wills and that's the
thing when you go to war the only reason
you're going to war is you don't know
who has the stronger will because if you
knew you wouldn't go if you look at
someone and go Yep they're gonna go and
they're never gonna stop then you say
hey this isn't a good thing to engage in
and so who's got the stronger will in
Vietnam you know we thought after the
battle of I drink like oh we killed 100
150 to one we're gonna beat them we got
air power we're going to beat them we
didn't realize that they didn't care if
they lost 150 they didn't care if they
lost 150 000 they didn't care if they
lost a million well
that statement right there applied to
Ukraine the simple arithmetic of Vietnam
when when Westmoreland every day at four
o'clock at the infamous four o'clock
Follies would talk about body counts in
the so-called strategy which was no
strategy but
was the closest thing I guess they had
to his strategy was attrition
and nobody ever stopped to look at the
simple arithmetic that the the birth
rate in Hanoi always exceeded the
attrition rate in the South ensuring an
unlimited supply of manpower
and it's the same and right now the you
know the ukrainians are brave as hell
but if if Putin's prepared to sacrifice
all the Russians that it takes which all
indications are he will
he'll grind them down they can't win
he'll kill you know we'll we'll fight to
the last Ukrainian yeah yeah or and this
is what we don't know we don't know if
the Russian popular population says hey
you know what I'm saying not sending my
kid or I'm not gonna go and if that
happens things go the other way history
doesn't support that that is true the
Russians just switch it up another notch
and the Russians know how to suffer yeah
yeah
sure uh but you get in the end it's a
test of Wills that you don't know what
the answer is you don't know who has the
stronger will I mean look the ukrainians
obviously have an incredible will it's
their Homeland it's their houses it's
their country they're going to have an
incredible will but
at the end of the day you're going to
end up with this if you end up in
attrition fight
and we just the Russians can keep
pouring bodies out it's terrible maybe
what we ought to do is take all his
resources or put it and put them into
into stockpiles and caches in various
places
so they'll invite the Russians in and
let the ukrainians go at them with
Gorilla activities because I I have been
very surprised that the ukrainians
didn't go into that already yeah I mean
they have well-trained snipers they
could kill they could kill a hundred
Russians a day just without engaging
them in any attrition ground you know uh
force on Force peer-to-peer combat well
it doesn't make sense to do that so
they're gonna figure I mean it seems
like they're going to have to figure
that out is we we can't beat them with
numbers we need to beat them with
guerrilla warfare and and
we'll see what they do be interesting by
the way back to the back to the dredges
on iPhone
I went back to Hanoi before Americans
were allowed to go back
because I was working with a guy in Hong
Kong hell of a guy and I was chairman of
the well we built the first office
building in Hanoi after the war right
next to the Metropol hotel near the what
year was operous this would have been
uh
early 90s okay what makes that
I have to think about that but yeah
uh it was before Woodcock went there and
did the
the water no that was late 70s wouldn't
it I think that was in the 70s yeah so
it would have been somewhere in the 80s
I think yeah when I did that
anyway
um
so I I took a day off by the way
Vietnamese at this time this everything
was still raw
Vietnamese were gracious as could be
because of course they had won
they could afford to be and they were in
the young ones were interested in
building what they've subsequently
building
but uh during I during one of the days
to say you guys you got excuse me I got
to get a taxi and I gotta go take a
drive to high fall I got to see those
dredges
so I drove up there
there's still there's still all kinds of
bomb damage all over the place I look
over at this Narrow Gauge Railroad an
average guy where it was that's where
all this stuff was coming down a Narrow
Gauge Railroad
so much the stuff's going because the
roads weren't any good
a couple of bridges were still damaged
but the nail gate rear which was just I
mean I I kept saying how could they move
all this tonnage how could they move all
this stuff South okay and and if you
were paying any attention at all
I mean it's like it's a story I don't
know if somebody I'd like to if I could
be here in a couple of more days I would
see Ron Bell who's going to be here for
the old frogs and things that bill
Schultz does
and because he's reputedly the first
seal that went into a tunnel I went into
a coochie tunnel I don't know if this is
true story or not but and and supposedly
Bell came out it only said these guys
prepare to live like this we can there's
no way we're going to win
yeah and that would have been about 66
or 67 probably
so
um to where the barge is still there
when you went there yeah there were the
two dredges
it was incredible anyway so we so we we
took the back to iPhone May and on new
so they were in the sort of the roads so
when we hit on me and I knew and did
some damage I think that it provoked
some kind of a retaliation now what the
retaliation was I'm not sure who's
who's uh
story I believe
but they they were really uh
if that that's what led you know then
after that gave Nicole photonka an
incident yeah you say up here when we
sent the nasties up there knowing they'd
get the job done quickly these islands
are in the direct path the entrances to
the harbor and hitting them could have
been considered a threat to the harbor
itself we came in Fast and hit the
targets hard and successfully when we
finished North Vietnamese Patrol craft
came after us with a fury chasing us
back down toward Danang our boats outran
them somewhere north of the 17th
parallel those North Vietnamese boats
that were chasing us that night were the
ones that allegedly attacked the USS
Maddox and the USS Turner Joy and our
attacks on them most likely triggered
their strategy to engage the U.S in
retaliation
what happened with us and the Turner joy
and Maddox on that night would result in
the joint Congressional Tonkin Gulf
resolution Which authorized President
Johnson to escalate U.S military efforts
in Vietnam
would have not have attributed any
nefarious motives
to those decisions
an older and more cynical Jamal's
would attribute it to selfish political
reasons
and I wish I under I wish I knew the
truth
so I'm going to read this section here
you say younger seals
which I am one cannot appreciate the
atmosphere in those days the Frogman and
early seals were barely tolerated by the
traditional Navy and 34A was the most
politically sensitive operation in the
country ignorance and disinterest in
covert operations along with security
compartmentalization made it inevitable
that the Navy would appoint an officer
in charge with no training no experience
no interest in a vessel smaller than a
destroyer so you're dealing with this
guy and all that you were doing there
you say but dealing with that was part
of what I had to go through in Vietnam
in order to be prepared for the Congo
there I learned the clandestine art of
plausible deniability and gathered the
experience that led me to build and lead
a mercenary Navy for the CIA I was
incredibly lucky I was being paid to do
what what I would have done for free
um
this is just a little bit of information
here
you say while I was learning covert Ops
on the job in Vietnam the Cold War was
heating up in Africa what preceded my
arrival in the Congo was an
extraordinary effort that included the
talents of an American operator Jordy
McKay he did everything he was supposed
to do and more as a one-man show McKay
was in the Congo to work with five
Commando as he made up the entirety of
the U.S clandestine Maritime
paramilitary team the agency had sent
him there before they sent me and no
contribution was more vital than two
Mission success than McKay's but through
an event in the middle of a crucial
battle McKay made a judgment and acted
on it and it was exactly the wrong
decision according to the state
department because of that the operation
inevitable the operation became
available to me but the groundwork for
our mission success lay in actions McKay
took at a place called Fitzy Baraka am I
saying that right fizzy so it's just
like it's written fizzy Baraka so now
we're talking it's 1965 live the Congo
Battlefield that heated and cooled to a
varying degree of ferocity over the
preceding several years the symbol Simba
Rebels and these are communist rebels
were a ragtag bunch of untrained
Renegades more interested in pillaging
the and Butchery than ideology or cause
but they began to receive the support of
communist advisors and troops who had
been training in Eastern Europe and
China and supplies of weapons and
ammunition steadily increased the U.S
worried that Soviet block reinforcement
and training the symbols might actually
turn into a coordinated fighting force
that that notion began to drive policy
you talk about and by the way um I
always have to say this I'm reading
chunks of this book I'm reading a small
percentage of the book there's all kinds
of details in here there's an incredible
story that's flowing through we're
hitting the highlights of it but get the
book so that you can get all these
details
some of the you talk about McKay McKay
left the Navy in 1950 to start a salvage
business in Cuba and eventually he gets
pressured out of Cuba by the communist
he gets put out of business the person
that put him out of business in Cuba was
there was the ministry of the minister
of Industry
which is a guy named Che Guevara that's
the guy who put McKay out of business
when he started this this uh this uh
company down in Cuba
and after he gets forced out of Cuba he
goes back to the CIA because he was in
the CIA before so uh
McKay and and we'll get into who he
links up with a guy named Lieutenant
girl Mad Mike
uh he's the commander of these five
Commando mercenaries and these guys kind
of join up they get some vessels
um the five Commando starts they start
doing basically amphibious operations
uh there's this giant Lake
how do you say that Lake Tanganyika
taganyika so
Tagan yika I'm gonna brutalize that one
450 miles long 50 miles wide tag Anika
second deepest lake in the world
and it's actually in between what two
countries it's between uh on the 110
stanzania and Burundi
and then Eastern Congo and it divides
those two countries so they have
um
they're they're running operations to
try and suppress these Rebels
and you say this during the assault
McKay would make a significant
difference in the war albeit hit by
making a conscious decision that would
contravene the CIA instructions
he wasn't supposed to be in the fight
the state department wanted no U.S
fingerprints on the operation and
plausible deniability was the purpose
behind using five Commando boat Crews if
a mercenary were killed in the Congo so
be it but if an American turned up shot
and dead there particularly an ex-navy
Personnel it would be much more
difficult to ignore and whitewash away
McKay was the only American officer
involved in the planning training and
preparation of this operation and
despite CIA instructions ultimately the
only one who unexpectedly ended up
engaged in combat so they're doing this
big amphibian amphibious operation and
again get the book there's really cool
details about it they do this amphibious
operation to land troops on the beach
they get resistance when they get on the
beach they start kind of they can't
really get off the beach for a while
and they're pinned down and you say this
as five Commando forces took casualties
they became bogged down around each hour
plus three the attack started to stall
these guys are short on ammunition and
over on the Left Flank of the of the
Landing Beach
there was this church and in the church
there was some snipers apparently that
were really reaping havoc on the five
Commando guys and so you say this McKay
went to the captain of the irmans and
this was the ship that they were using a
five Commando mercenary under horse
command and asked him to bring the boat
around
and also to get someone on the 75
millimeter recoilless perched on the
stern but there was no response McKay
face to face and Under Fire in the
middle of a battle stared
at a frozen Captain who would be could
gone gun shy without hesitation McKay
took control of the ship himself he
ordered the Helmsman to steer the
airmen's parallel to the beach until
they were approximately 150 meters
offshore and only 250 meters from The
Gun Nest
Michael called for a dead slow course
with the engine stopped and the irmands
began taking direct enemy fire McKay ran
to the AFT deck and got onto the giant
75 millimeter weapon he had bore sighted
and tested the rifle the day before so
he could fire with accuracy he loaded
the recoilers took aim and fired the
powerful weapon at the steeple where the
hidden Gunners continued to pin down the
landing troops his first shot was a
bullseye the heavy rounds inside of the
recoilless struck
the Machine Gun Nest with a force that
demolished the steeple two bodies were
flung into the air like a pair of
ragdolls as the nest was splintered and
blown apart the Gunners were silenced
Lieutenant Colonel began to plan a
breakout that would take troops into the
interior from fizzy to pursue the
retreating simbas he buried his 5K IAS
the enemy count was 215.
um so this is like before you get there
and this guy McKay after this happens he
finds out that his father had died his
father was a cop a New York NYPD
detective his father had a heart attack
he goes home
when he gets home it sounds like they
say hey look you were out there doing
what you weren't supposed to be doing
and they kind of don't let him come back
to the Congo the state department wants
you to do he wants you to be successful
in your mission but not break any rules
the CIA wants you to be successful in
your mission and not get caught
breaking any rules
oh how did he get caught it's my
observation how did he get caught
oh
or
my core was the the most
notorious mercenary of the 20th century
by far you hear about Blackjack SRAM and
some of these other guys they were
nothing compared to or sorry
yeah they were nothing compared to work
among
and and I don't like Corp but I think he
was exactly the right guy for the job
and we worked together just fine I
didn't like him because to me he was too
much of a prima donna
and and that's one example right there
he invited two
American correspondents oh that's this
and of course that was a No-No but it
served him it served him well
and and fortunately there were they were
all style correspondents because they
kept their word on not disclosing
anything about American presence
but uh
uh it was enough to get so that the
state department was able to find out
and so they uh they just leaned on
they leaned on Africa division which
would be more
politically sensitive than the Special
Operations Division so so I was it was
really interesting the the African
division wanted some of them not all of
them of course wanted to hammer him and
the Special Operations wanted to to
order the award in in Bill Hamilton the
old Faro frog father yeah was very
instrumental in in protecting
uh Jordy
and um
so he went on spent another you know
what 30 40 years and he didn't retire
until his early 80s
so but but not in Africa
uh meanwhile as that's happening you
are you get orders I think you get
orders so that you can you know your
next assignment is to take a platoon to
Vietnam
but you're still in Vietnam at the time
yeah I volunteered you have to to take
the first attachment to this to the
delta
so that call comes in you're you say hey
look I'll go
and you say hey can you send me a
replacement
because I want to get back and start
training with my yeah it's a total
different type of operation right of
course so
you say can you send me a replacement
and bupers which is the the Bureau of
Navy personnel this is sort of the
nightmarish bureaucracy that anyone
would think of this big giant
organization that's you know doesn't
think of people as people but as numbers
and billets
so you say can you send me a replacement
well they don't send you your
replacement so sorry we can't we just
can't we can't too late can't do it it's
too late so you wait
you're waiting so I said okay I'll just
get a half of a training session
whatever yeah but then your replacement
finally shows up two Replacements two
Replacements finally show up
and you you know you're just hey welcome
one of the guys I'm with you training
with
and you say Hey you know welcome here's
what we're doing
I you say something along the lines of
and you've got it in the book but you
know I I wish you guys could have gotten
here a little earlier and the guy looks
at you and goes I've I haven't I could
have come anytime I've been totally free
and you got you got so so frustrated
that you uh
well it was the not it was the Cavalier
attitude or the nonchalance or the
whatever the just Jesus it just it hit
me at the exactly the wrong at the wrong
time just the fact that bupr is yeah
could have sent the replacement here you
are getting you're in war you're getting
ready to go back to War I just need a
replacement and they just didn't do
anything about it here's this guy going
yeah I could have come months ago it
doesn't matter yeah and you got so
pissed off yeah that you called bupers
oh I picked up the phone and got it
right in those days with Saigon
switchboard Honolulu switchboard right
to right to Butte purse
I would I I said my name is Hawes my
file number is
653959 I'm on a voluntary extension I
want out of this Navy right now
on a volunteer extension boom and comes
a set of orders
goodbye
[Laughter]
that was it I mean San Francisco
mustard out
and then uh started making a slow slow
drive across the coast because this time
I'd cool off and said geez you love what
you're doing what the hell did you do
I'm constantly telling people not to
make decisions when they're emotional
this is why because you're in the
freaking teams you have the best job in
the world you get pissed off yeah and so
you say I'm gonna get out uh you start
driving across
back towards the east coast
um at some point you get a call from one
of your one of your buddies well I'm
already back on I'm back on the on the
East Coast I'm back in Little Creek so
what are you doing are you just like
going reacquainting some uh
reacquainting with some old friends how
long had it been how long had it been
since you uh since you got out when you
showed back up at the teams oh like you
just drove across country yeah week or
whatever yeah well probably maybe a
month because I stopped and stopped to
see my folks did you and were you
thinking Ham's gonna get back in yeah I
thought what it is yeah sure I couldn't
think anything I'd rather do yeah and
it's not not that hard I remember
talking to Dick Thompson you know the
song guy
and you know he had he was his officer
Green Beret and and SOG and I said was
it I said was it hard to you know become
an officer and he was like no we just
signed up and I go was it hard to get
selected for Special Forces he goes no
he just had to go and it was it hard to
get in a sock he said no and he's like
it was Vietnam no one wanted to be doing
this stuff there was no waiting line at
the door to do any of this stuff all I
had to do is call Starbucks and
Starbucks would you make that happen
so that was the plan that was the plan
and then I get the call from Phil and
what what was Phil's situation well Phil
was a blank owner in Seal Team One
Phil Gaddis playing yeah yeah yeah and
he uh
not his true name of course and um
Phil had been one of the first seals to
go to Vietnam in 62 or whenever it was
earlier one of the first detachments
that went about a handful of guys went
over Philip was the officer in charge
a really really smart guy a really good
guy Harvard guy Harvard graduate
um
great physically
good guy and his wife was at least as
smart as he was and she was actually
just as an aside
um when they made all the uh when they
made all the uh dependents leave Vietnam
they forgot Barbara was in Da Nang so
Barbara kept crying they all kept
everybody kept quiet so Barbara stayed
in the name for quite a long time until
someone realized he was there by the
time she left she could speak read and
write Vietnamese and she was a hell of
an asset to have but anyway
um yeah so Phil a Phil had
Phil was the only other seal officer
with with uh Swift boat experience
and he had been the year that I was
there he had been he was ship sheep
dipped in the agency and he was there
but he was doing other things he wasn't
in much involved in our operations
um and he was getting out of the Navy he
had been in rootc and his time was
always again he was going to go to the
CIA Career Training Program
so he called me he called me and said
Jim he said they want me to go to the
Congo and I'm starting the Career
Training Program and Barbara's about to
pop he said I really don't want to go
but I don't want to say I don't want to
go are you interested and I said you
mean I'll get paid
[Laughter]
yeah I said let's you know let's do it
so bill in Bill Hamilton was the was the
chief of the maritime Branch the CIA and
Bill Hamilton just he using frog man oh
what a pilot and just like an absolute
everything he's like he he was like this
is delicate so I got to be careful
because I'm not sure you know strongly I
believe it myself but
in those days officers knew they were
going to make Admiral
so was the team the teams the teams
that's why we survived in my opinion
because guys like Fain and Hamilton and
so forth and and what's his name from uh
dell Judas and so forth they all did the
things necessary to
to keep the teams alive and it wasn't
about when am I going to get my stars
uh anyway Hamilton Naval Academy
graduate son of an admiral
Naval aviator in Korea and he says I
want to be a frog man so he he comes and
he is uh
he becomes Udu
2 which is underwater demolition which
is in charge of the
the the the the teams the UDT teams and
the uh I think Beach jumpers or
something else at the time whatever
anyways he was the senior senior frog
and and he was uh God he had it all he
was big handsome
outgoing guy smart as hell and he's you
know the kind of guy you needed to Keep
Us Alive basically
which he helped do at opnev when the
seals were formed he was in the right
place at the right time
and uh you know the East Coast and West
Coast have stupid arguments about who in
those days about who is the most
important well they were all important
but he was really important okay so
um
and now so yeah so now he's he's had a
maritime branch in the Sierra so so I
get a call from Bill and sister come on
up let's talk I said okay so I go up and
he of course by that I need to know
trouble checking me out as an individual
he just wanted to know if I knew
anything about Swifts
because and I didn't know why but he you
know he asked you some questions
obviously you know what I was talking
about about Swift so that was it he said
okay let's go you know get ready you got
to get out there right now
so he takes me to see uh a guy named
cheever who was the head of Special
Operations Division a retired Marine
Colonel smart guy can you imagine I go
and talk to this guy and he's got to
decide whether or not this kid
is he should go to the middle of the
Congo Hall by himself with all the
weapons and cash that it takes to do it
and you're 26 years old 25 to 25 26 yeah
I think that's 25 or 26 whatever and
he's got to make the decision and you're
you're out of the Navy so you're
civilian oh yes more civilian yeah right
and uh so I passed that to pass that
test and uh and then he says uh you know
probably I'd have some idea who you're
working for so I I go down to uh
so they send me to uh to uh orientation
course down in uh outside of Marana yeah
Miranda yeah at Morena and uh which was
a also a
a training place for smoke jumpers and
it's also where they they train their
kickers for Laos
if it'll kickers for a lot so most of
them have been smoke jumpers okay so I
went down there and got uh got you know
got sort of an orientation program and
then I
came back and
went around headquarters to get what I
needed and uh what a wonderful thing it
was like boy when you had an emergency
it was like everybody said hooray we got
an emergency and everybody woke up and
couldn't you know couldn't do enough for
you it was really it was extraordinary
so yeah so I I
went out there and said Dick Johnson
will meet you he's going to be your boss
and you'll find out what you need to
know
so you say uh I arrived in the capital
of leopoldville on a commercial UTA
flight from Paris with 2500 in cash
stuffed in my socks and a quantity of
morphine filled syringes in my bag I
knew there would never leave be
casualties and CIA Supply and Logistics
made sure I had I had what I needed to
help get the job done so you just
rolling in there what was your cover
well when I got on the plane I was
Department of the army
excuse me Department of the Navy or
something when I got off the plane I was
a department of art I don't I can't even
remember because nobody ever asked me no
one cared me nobody cared yeah nobody
cared but I had one it was flimsy but
yeah
um
then you leave
leopoldville for Albertville
which is now called kalimi yeah and
what's leopoldville called now
um
you say this I began to learn everything
in this operation be different my SEAL
training and Vietnam experience included
highly skilled professionals and
state-of-the-art resources immediately
at hand in the military had also been
accustomed to a formal structure of
working with other troops and adhering
to a coordinated strategy and where in
Vietnam and where Vietnam may have been
the precedent for this new practical
reality this was a remote Enterprise
where I went from high tech to no Tech
there were no historical how to's and no
one with previous experience to give me
direction or assistance once in
Albertville I was completely on my own
no one was there to meet me no crew
existed and few available Boats were in
need of substantial repair
in this remote corner of Africa the CIA
just expected me to handle things on my
own and go out and get the job done
that's exactly what I did well I mean
dick was Dick was terrific he was a
World War II Marine
uh would have been this is Dick Johnson
yeah Dick Johnson and what was his
position he was the head of all military
uh paramilitary activities in the Congo
working for Larry Devon who was the
chief of station
and he had been a chief of station
himself he was a really experienced guy
and just a just a terrific fellow but
but he basically said look after you
decide I was he was going to keep me
because I had to go right at his
uh stamp of approval in order to stay
because he could have sent me home
after uh you know he just said look I'll
help you any way I can but it's not much
I can do it's 2 000 miles across the
jungle over there
you just got to figure it out
so
anyway one more can a guy ask for yeah
gee that's tough
please
[Laughter]
here's your intro to five Commando you
say this I knew these guys were five
Commando Mercenaries
tenant Colonel Mad Mike troops
probably the most famous mercenary in
modern history the colorful Mad Mike had
collected a hodgepodge of experienced
soldiers Pretenders and combat cast offs
the way others collected stamps he had
the uh he had ability and Charisma and
he never shied away from an opportunity
to inflate his reputation his exploits
in Africa are said to be the inspiration
for Daniel Carney's novel and film The
Wild Geese which starred Richard Burton
and Roger Moore over the next few months
I would learn firsthand of the vicious
nature of this five Commando band of cut
throats the way they almost revered a
code of duplicity instead of loyalty and
how their ruthless tactics adhered only
to a pale version of military standard
these all-white paramilitaries from
former British colonies in Africa Europe
and the UK were definitely not your
well-disciplined combat troops they had
little respect for treatment of
civilians and property particularly
safes and they would demonstrate their
Shady conduct many times while I worked
with them
then you've got a story in here about
it's it's kind of how you formed your
quick reputation with them they were
trying to get into a safe and they were
trying to blow it open and they didn't
know what they were doing
um and you helped them blow the safe
open and then when they talked about you
know how they're going to divide what
was in it you were like hey I'm not here
for that
uh did you know what what Intel did you
have on five Commando when you showed up
there
what you just read that's it these guys
are just running around causing Mayhem
they would sign contracts and I can't
remember a six months contract storm and
the quality of a deteriorated over time
because it was a nasty environment and I
mean if it wasn't
you know if it wasn't as Simba's it was
uh hemorrhagic doing a fever or whatever
so the quality of the people who are who
are signing contracts deteriorated over
the time so by the end it was real drugs
I mean not that
yeah there were some real tricks they're
all there were a few among solos who
were first class who were first-class
soldiers but not many
and the ones that were were
when I say first class soldiers they had
the they had the soldier skills
but
yeah because otherwise they'd be still
in the British army or whatever
mentality was yeah whatever
uh
you you now you're you're starting you
have to you you got to work with them I
mean that's just the way it is
well the Leadership Lessons they imagine
this they were Mercenaries
I mean the first thing the first thing
they did when we hit a new town was half
of them peeled off to get the
missionaries and half peeled off to get
the banks
okay so they were mercenaries I didn't
pay them
uh they were five Commando I wasn't I
wasn't in their chain of command
um they didn't have to take any orders
for me so I had to make sure but I'd get
him to take orders for me
um if there was any discipline to be
done
I had to say what needed to be done and
not any and it would get done but I had
no no official position in any of this
so
um
I can't think of I couldn't have been
better prepared than for heaven and the
seal to do it they're really good in it
and when I got in in where I and what
really helped was Instinct Instinct that
was honed in training and in Vietnam
because you know when I get when I
finish Harvard Business School I had
unlearned instinct
took me a long time to realize how one
mistake that was and to get back to
trust in my instincts which were pretty
good
this is a kind of a cool along those
lines you say the event that it
contributed more to any other toward the
success of the force Naval Congolese am
I saying that right yeah
was the recruitment you know I don't
absolutely know for sure that's just
what I named it okay
sounds good I don't know if the grammar
is perfect or not
uh was the recruitment of five Commandos
regimental sergeant major Samuel Jacques
Cassidy
he had trained every five Commando
mercenary in the country and was a
hardened Soldier of Fortune a veteran of
Congo and mercenary Warfare the key to
his real value was the Personnel files
he held in his head acquiring Cassidy
with his knowledge and assessment of the
troops meant that I might be able to
recruit The Best of The Mercenaries and
if I could do that I'd assemble a Navy
with the capabilities to accomplish the
mission Cassidy was older than I was and
I knew him as a murderer and a plunderer
with a hair trigger that often led to
violence he was tough mean tough and the
word on him was that he had racked up a
catalog of savage acts that had earned
the fear of every mercenary working in
the Congo and many other parts of Africa
instinctively I addressed him as if he
were a UDT SEAL trainee which was a
direct line back to the year I'd spend
his instructor thank you Captain Lee
Instinct instinct and you say uh we're
gonna build a Navy I told him with or
without you but if you come on board
together we'll make an effective force
in this War I forced him to stand as if
he were a subordinate officer and he
stared at me with a lacerating glare I
know you're a mercenary I continued but
I will not bid against Lieutenant
Lieutenant Colonel horror for your
services I was in my element and felt as
though I had the upper hand in this
conversation because I had a desirable
card to play so I sweetened the pot what
I will do I told him is see to it that
you are commissioned as a lieutenant and
if you are as good as you are reputed to
be and I believe you are I'll make you
captain
Cassidy nodded in agreement and you kept
the Army ranks you go into that a little
bit then you say weeks later uh you guys
had a conversation about this Cassidy
finally gave me his impression of this
initial meeting Commander he said I
trained every mercenary and five
Commando and no one including Lieutenant
Colonel ever talk to me the way
you did on that first day I didn't know
whether to join you or kill you luckily
for us both I signed on once again the
old adage better lucky than good proved
valid whatever his reasoning we were now
working as a team we set our sights on
assembling a Congo Navy
so thank you Solinski and Blaze and all
those instructors I can't tell you
it was you know a boy why didn't this
you know that um yeah I can't tell you
it just turned out right I said I guess
again God wanted
God wanted to be a good frog man
you give background on Lieutenant
Colonel horror you say his transition to
Adventure came out of unlikely
circumstances like many people who have
lived a bland liked horse personal
history might seem obscure and
nondescript right up to the point where
he first gained notoriety and that
happened in the Congo he was born in
India served in Lord mountbatten's staff
in World War II in the British Army in
South Asia had been educated as a as a
chartered accountant hardly rigorous
prerequisites for a mercenary Commander
but through a friend he was introduced
to one of the convo's most powerful
political figures
um moist chombie yeah the governor of
the Breakaway katanga Province and once
he was in he took full advantage some of
his critics would label horror puff it
puppet Which is far from accurate
ability to act his role was
crucial to commanding a mercenary Army
particularly because he had no formal
judicial recourse structure what he did
was have good fundamental military
skills and that meant he could recognize
those same skills and others and employ
them and employ them accordingly he
masterfully played above the riffraff
the role of a British gentleman officer
tapped to lead mercenary troops in
overcoming a communist threat his
theater of war was a small but important
strategic part of the cold world Cold
War World he had an acute sense for both
strategy and tactics and I saw him
juggle cold-blooded Killers African
leaders and U.S embassy employees with a
plum while still focusing on chasing
down and destroying the rebels
great respect for him I didn't like him
but I had a lot of respect what was it
you didn't like about him
to his I didn't like his ego
I don't you know Eagle guy he got he
goes always gets you in difficulty yeah
Subway
and in uh that other than that no I
think and he uh he very resented me uh
because he he didn't want the Navy to be
separate from his command oh and I knew
I and and I knew that dick Johnson would
back me up as long as I was doing the
right things for the right reason
and I um and he wasn't going to bug Dick
Johnson
and uh
uh so
I say look my primary reason to be here
is interdiction I said you watch we'll
support you you'll get all the support
you could possibly want but but my
primary Mission here is interdiction and
that's I don't need any help thank you
and he had a hard time with that for a
little while but it ended up working out
just fine we would meet every day about
four o'clock to talk about the next next
days or next upcoming operations and so
forth then we did we supported him very
well and that problem went away
but
you start scrounging up but he never
liked me because I'm you know because
his ego wouldn't he must have been he
must have been what 50 years old
I mean if using World War II yeah he
must have been 50 years old and you're
26 year old yeah little little punk ass
frog man exactly
exactly he had actually had his wife
with him for much of his campaigning and
she had a baby a long way she was and
she was great looking and tough as could
be
uh he's written a couple of books that
are good reads no I'll check those out
you should do that
so now you start scrounging up boats uh
you got the boat called the kivu are you
saying that right the kivu
and it was uh you liked it because it
was built in 1910 but you liked it
because you could
um basically help recruit oh it was a
great recruiting tool because it it was
a bear and we made it a Barracks vessel
so they could eat they could eat good
and sleep clean and did their own Cooks
like those five those army gun Five
Command army guys but oh don't look
terrible so that since it was a hell of
a recruiting tool so with with that plus
Cassidy's knowledge of the individuals
that was another reason horror got a
little resentful I took away
and yet you didn't pay him you didn't
pay Cassidy so what was how was he
making money I mean oh he used to get
paid five they were in five Commandos so
they got paid their Five Command no
money plus all the money they could uh
they could pill each other they could
plunder but he still kept getting paid
by five Commando even when he works
because you're all part of one big
mission they were all five commits still
five commando but they were under my um
my uh jurisdiction who was paying five
Commando well ostensibly the Congolese
government getting funneled through
American Cash exactly
that's what I'm saying he wouldn't do
anything in the book yeah Dick Johnson
which means he was bucking Larry devil
in the chief of station and he ended
devil liked him the devil called him a
a
what do you call a gentleman um it was a
British it would be a British expression
a British expression for a company a
gentleman Adventurer and that's not the
exact term but it's close an adventurer
and they stayed they were friends till
uh till Devlin died yeah
so he didn't want to rock the boat with
you no he wouldn't he knew who he was
writing his paychecks yeah and and those
had to be some fat paychecks I have no
idea but the US government doesn't
never asking I have no idea Plus
uh you know as I said he pretended to be
above The Fray but Cassidy and John
Peters
who if anybody was meaner than Cassidy
was John Peters what did you what did
you heard about Cassidy like you're
calling him a murderer and all this
stuff in the book like what what did you
heard about him that's what I'd heard
about him he would just kill people yeah
I mean he when he got drunk yeah you
wouldn't do it unless he was drunk okay
but he had a bad liver
but anyway he in fact he was away on
medical leave when I arrived that's when
I heard about him and so I got word to
him as soon as he came when I heard he
was coming back to come and see me so
before could get his hands on him
or do anything and by and by I'd also
some I can't tell you now how I
realized I came to realize that the
thing he wanted was to be an officer be
get commission be the whatever and he
had never could do that under
because these two valuable the
regimental sergeant major
so but it's interesting like you're
wanting to be commissioned as an officer
in five Commando a random mercenary
group right well there you go yeah and
there's no pension that comes with it or
anything that's right
uh you say here fast forward in a little
bit uh things were beginning to fall
into place our primary focus now had to
be on the boats we had a few smaller
boats exaggeratedly termed pts which
were operated from the irmaans the 250
ton Lake vessel that we inherited from
McKay and commandeered for the Navy we
called the irmans the mothership she was
the command operations vessel for the
for the pts and armed with captured
Russian weapons including a 12.7
millimeter Russian machine guns and a
U.S 75 millimeter recoilless rifle
the euromones had radar on it you talk
about that
um
then you say here Peter Jessup of the
national security staff wrote a member
to President Johnson stating that a more
substantial pocket Coast Guard is
necessary
he approved the purchase transport and
by air and Armament and Manning of six
additional boats two Swifts and four sea
crafts so they are getting a word that
you need more support over there oh yeah
and remember that was all at the
beginning I mean uh yeah again Hamilton
and his Deputy Tom Clines who the hell
of a guy and the guy who the Cubans
totally trusted them when we get into
that story you you learn the new
definition of the word trust
um anyway so Hamilton and uh who got
these got these Swifts and uh went down
to Seward seacraft in Louisiana where
they were built and got the got the
Cajuns to come on board and his only
animal could sell it you know he
basically we cut the superstructure cut
cut the bow cut the superstructure cut
the hole longitudinally
threw everything into globemasters flew
it into the scenario this strip next to
kalimi there's a nail grade railroad put
it on that put it over to the port
brought the coonasses out or sorry the
Cajuns uh you can call them coonasses if
you're their buddy
and uh brought the Cajuns out in the
cages I'm not sure where the Cajuns even
knew where they were because it was hot
and humid and everybody was black but
whatever it was they did their they they
were terrific I mean these guys work
like hell they have cold beer at the end
laugh at the end of the day and up the
next morning everyone thought it'd take
a month it took them like a week or two
to get the votes but were those two
boats those were two boats were those
were the ones that had been used in the
Antichrist Castro Maritime rates yeah so
they they take these boats that's just
any you go into the details on the story
but um
when you talk about clients
um
you know he said here well first of all
why when you talk about clients and in
his relationship with the Cubans what
was that relationship based on uh all
the uh anti-castro stuff out of Miami
they had just they had just been working
together
um they trusted him I mean they didn't
even know where they were going
and and These Guys these Cubans get
basically turned over to you yeah and
and you say here clients would turn the
Cuban contingent over to me with a
message these men are tough respect
tough resourceful and brave and take
pride in their performance but Above All
Else they're loyal Chavez is a proven
leader and the men believe in him so
there will be no discipline problems
over the years we have developed a
trusting relationship based on shared
experiences and I am assigning these
bonds of trust and friendship over to
you
when he endorsed the transferred
expectations to me I received a teen
prepared to work unconditionally under
my command no questions asked you're all
set clients told me now don't it up
exactly right so you had these Cuban
Americans yeah that this is after the
Bay of Pigs all that had happened and
there they had fought Castro they'd
fought communism they're now basically
in America mostly in Florida
they get this opportunity to go to
freaking couple of their pigs and had
been in prison who were liberated with
the tractors you know so they did they
get they get put together all right you
want to go fight the Communists we gotta
we got a spot for you yeah it's in Congo
Africa and they say hell yeah let's go
I mean those guys I cannot tell you we
do not have one single discipline
problem we didn't have any other kind of
these guys were so professional so it
you know I like it did my boat crew in
training I had such a boat crew I just
had to not fall out of the boat yeah
you know what's interesting these Cubans
were almost the same thing they were I
was talking to a friend of mine
yesterday who said as long as I had him
yeah a friend of mine yesterday was a
Cuban American who came over on the
boats and he said his you know his mom
and dad his dad wanted to come to
America his mom was like hey it's not
that bad here I got my family here we're
gonna stay
and finally they started taking they
started taking the Cuban military-aged
males and saying You're Gonna Go an
African fight for communism and when he
when the mom heard that she said we're
out and they came to America so that
that's how much they like number one
they were willing to sacrifice
everything to get away from communism
um and also the fact that the Cuban
Communists were exporting fighters to go
overseas it was a really interesting
yeah that I had this conversation
yesterday with a guy who's like oh yeah
that's one of the reasons we left is my
mom didn't want me to get sent to Africa
to fight for communism nope not
happening when I started to write this
book which was I really wrote most of it
25 years ago because I didn't want to
you know the older you get the smarter
tougher faster stronger you were
and us trying to avoid that and I went
to the Swiss Embassy see in Washington
which is where they were had whatever
they call a representative thing of the
Cubans
and uh I met a Cuban guy who was the
first Secretary very bright very
articulate whatever it is like I'm gonna
write this book it's you know there's a
lot of you guys in this
um I said I'd like to talk to the guy
who was in charge who at this point was
on the pilot Bureau of uh in in Havana
and I said uh he said I think that's I
said I like you know I want to put your
side of the story in
and he he thought that was just a great
idea so he got a hold of those guys but
they wouldn't cooperating so I said okay
I'll with you it was it but
um you talked a little bit about these
guys with the the uh
showing up with those boats that you you
talk about a guy named Joe bresch
um who showed up
engine Man shows up with the Cajun
Builders this is just like a crazy story
yeah uh Bill Bain an old frog Man shows
up he's another one of these guys Bill
Banker he was a World War II guy when
another one of the World War II got he
could do anything I mean he was you know
talk about the utility player god the
guy who was gonna do anything so yeah
that was all all part of the team that
Hamilton assembled
you know to sort of help make me look
good yeah when interviewed for this book
Bouchard and that's the guy who's
running the the Cajuns about the job his
crew did the CIA had apparently expected
the Reconstruction would take them two
or three months to complete he and his
team did it in a month he said I'm not
gonna brag he said I'm gonna brag we
were expert at this stuff we built them
from the keel up I worked on the boats
when I first went to uh Seward and we
knew every piece of the boat we knew
what we were fooling with the Cajuns
slipped into the country undetected
black in blackout in the vernacular of
the CIA
and there you go you know sewer of
course died and he sold it and it's
companies called Swift ships or
something right now and I tried to get a
hold of those guys because I thought boy
this was they they'd love this because
the these are their sons are probably
working in the shipyard yeah you know
grandsons whatever no I never got a
reply never got a reply they might reach
out to you now uh the Swifts were
powered by high performance Detroit
Diesel gmv 1271 engines that were
extremely reliable as were the inboard
outboard gasoline engines on the little
pts but maintenance and repair
requirements were inevitable locally the
capabilities to perform that kind of
work just didn't exist Bill Hamilton
looked to the teams for support and he
knew the right person for the job Renee
Goff
known as gooch when Hamilton was the
commander of underwater demolition unit
at Naval Amphibious Base in Little Creek
Virginia Gooch served as a frog man with
a specialty as an engineman he stayed in
that post until his retirement when he
left Virginia Beach and headed for an
idyllic Caribbean spot in Saint Thomas
with his wife and four children they had
all sailed down to the Caribbean on a
57-foot retired oyster boat a type of
vessel known as a Chesapeake Bay skip
Jack which he had converted into a fan
floating Family Residence
they had endured hurricane force winds a
rejected Sanctuary Landing in Haiti by
papadoc paranoid papadox paranoid regime
and the impasse of the doldrum in the
sargasso sea before pitching up for a
couple of years on an idyllic Island
living aboard a sailboat fishing and
enjoying being a family again
then the CIA came calling about a
one-of-a-kind mission in the congoever
the dedicated frog man Gooch said Gooch
could not say no to his old Commander
this veteran old frog would provide
agent experience because at 26 I was
decidedly short on both he was the kind
of guy who could do anything a good
sailor a brilliant engineman and a
confident and selfless friend Gooch had
the perfect demeanor for the job and
when he arrived in the Congo he made an
immediate impact on the smooth running
of our operations
that's a terrific guy wow I wasn't
allowed to you know when when he died uh
Cassie and I had to find a pound had to
hammer or gather together a casket
and then wrapped him in a heavy sail
cloth
and managed to find a cold spot until I
could get a plane over to get his body
out to get him back to leopoldville
I was never led to speak to his family
the agency took care of him of course
but I was never allowed to speak to him
until about the time this until this
thing came out and we've become you know
friends and so forth since I've never
forgiven myself for obeying that order
wasn't the right thing to do I mean I
understand the reasoning behind it but
it wasn't the right thing to do anyway
it wasn't the right thing for me to do
yeah but anyway
he was he was just a remarkable guy and
a hell of a friend and uh Helper and
advisor and
I get along with everybody and
mercenaries all like them the Cubans
adored him yeah he was a great guy
and he could uh again he could fix
anything yeah I guess if you take a
skipjack tuna turn it into a living
quarters you can do anything he sure
could
and keep your wife happy while you're
doing it that's double impressive yeah
you say here when I first learned the
Cubans would be coming to train the five
Commando mercenaries I realized there
might be a potential problem The
Mercenaries had a range of motivations
for being in the Congo some were
strictly there for money being paid for
professional soldiering but others were
perverted so perverted and deranged they
were just there because they wanted to
kill kafirs the pejorative South African
term for blacks fighting in the Congo
conflict enabled them to do this and get
paid for it because some of the Cubans
or dark complexioned I needed to make
sure that before they arrived they would
be a lot they would be allowed to have a
smooth introduction into the equation I
approached Jacques Cassidy jock these
Cubans are professionals they've been
fighting a real adversary not a bunch of
ganja hyped up teenage soldiers and they
know what they're doing after allowing
Cassidy to acknowledge this I proceeded
and some of the Cubans have dark
complexions so I'm holding you
responsible there better not be any
trouble Cassidy's reply was filled with
the perfect mercenary rationale no
problem Commander they ain't caverners
they're Cubans
and so our operation rolled on fueled by
a commitment to racial Harmony
that was such a funny incident don't
worry don't worry Commander they ain't
cappers they're cute
[Laughter]
oh Lord life of people Jesus
um
you I'm gonna fast for again there's so
many good great details in this book
um get the book you say here I'm going
to fast forward a little bit on December
30th Chavez so Chavez is your lead guy
of the Cubans that came and he's
basically the extraordinary
extraordinary leader of these Cubans and
he's out running operations yeah on
December 30th Chavez reported coming
across a boat on the lake they
maneuvered Lobo one these are some of
the again I'm fast forwarding but these
are the vessels that they they gave the
vessel's name Lobo one in a circle
around the small boat to take advantage
of the Moon to illuminate it the ship's
log notes that it was a boat with an
outboard motor a definite sign of a
rebel vessel Chavez ordered a high
firing and immediately the boat
attempted to get away Lobo won in a
Pursuit and instead of firing over their
heads the crew took aim at them for real
firing several rounds they approached
the boat slowly and found that everyone
on board had jumped into the lake and
was trying to swim away Chavez ordered a
slow speed chase dodging the rebels
through the water until they tired out
Lobos low 201 crew fired rounds into the
water just to scare the swimmers as
Chavez recorded they finally captured
the rebels and brought them on board the
Cubans were motivated by a general
hatred of Communism but they also
perceived early on in their recruiting
that something was happening in the
Congo that related to their Cuban
problem they would soon find out for
certain rumors circulated throughout
Miami that communist Cubans were
fighting in the Congo but no one knew
for sure if it was true or not until my
Navy crew confirmed it
um
here's another just
I mean you're you're in all you got
leadership challenges all over the place
down here here's fast forward a little
as well after midnight there was a loud
banging on my hotel room door even
though half asleep I instinctively
picked up my Walther PPK from the night
table and went reluctantly to the door
it's never good news at that hour I
eased the door open a severely enabled
inebriated Jacques Cassidy stood
swinging in the hallway behind him the
tall gangly Dern was quaking with fear
the color had drained from his face and
he was so pale with fright that he
almost seemed to glow in the dark I
shook my head at the side of them and
Cassidy immediately blurred out
Commander this insulted me in
front of the men
I thought about castie's foul temper and
having witnessed his vengeful brand of
discipline with the and this is another
story that you tell and hear about how
he handled somebody that had stolen
something I knew he was capable capable
of meeting out irrational punishment
Cassidy glare to Dern I'm going to kill
him he said his eyes flared with an
alarming rage that continued to build
and then I'm gonna burn down the Navy
I stepped back in my hotel room held the
door open a little wider as Cassidy
turned to Android motion to Dern to
stand fast I needed to defuse the
tension and do it quickly before Dern
did something really stupid my instincts
told me that I needed to maintain a
casual atmosphere in this situation come
on and I said tell me what happened
let's talk about it
so what was Dern's role over there well
they uh when we found out that uh that
Che was in the area they decided they
needed a a real Intel guy so they came
they came out and made he was chief of
Base which made him my boss in effect
but he didn't he didn't get it he didn't
interfere with anything I was doing but
he was there supposedly to try to
collect Intel
and uh I I I you can be careful about
his name because he's he's a bit of an
Israel name is a bit of a name in
Washington DC so
it tells you more about headquarters
mentality anyway
um
so uh
so he would I never drank with the
mercenaries I did one time I drank with
him one time I competitively shot with
him one time
so I made him think I could hold my
liquor which I can't
uh and again God wanted to make me a
successful frog man and I really hit
what I was shooting at they were
pointing at those days so I never did it
again never let them I
I was friendly I just kept a little
distance kept distance kept distance and
I did everything to jock
because I for some reason I had Jock's
total
total and the Congo definition of the
word
[Laughter]
total loyalty uh
but but uh what's his name Dern Dern um
he would go to the to the watering hole
and drink with these guys
stupid I mean they're they're they're
they're screwed up anyway they got
weapons on them and they got alcohol
well what the hell what's the definition
of trouble
oh I never not one time did I ever do
that he would go do it and I guess maybe
he thought he was collecting information
or something I don't know but he was
just drinking as far as I was concerned
so uh you know this is he insulted
Cassidy in front of the men or Cassie
thought he insulted it in front of the
men whichever it was
so then they come back to the come back
to the to the to the hotel du Lac and
there they are so uh shoe Dern away and
um
Cassie came in he said and he'd say
repeat himself I'm going to kill him and
burn down the Navy and I said jock I
don't give a if you kill him but
why would you want to burn down the Navy
we worked so hard to build you know
trying to do yeah anyway so that worked
and over the course of the next three or
four hours till Dawn and he sobered up a
little bit and then he I I said look
I'll keep I'll keep Dern away from the
Navy don't worry we'll just get on do
our stuff so okay that was agreeable to
him and so he staggered back to the Navy
to sleep it off and I went down to
Dern's room
thought dumbass had kept drinking
can you believe that and I said you know
I said
I don't know whether we can keep you
alive I said I don't know for sure I
said we'll try but my advice to you is
get out of here
he said yeah that's good advice
so that's when I had the story that's
when I had to talk with Gooch about how
we were going to have to kill Cassidy if
it came down to it it was either Cassidy
or dirt
and so that's that that's what that yeah
you came up you you and Gooch came up
with a whole plan yeah you have to kill
Cassidy because you couldn't obviously
let him kill this American yeah yeah
unfortunately uh fortunately uh Dern
took off and it was all dissipated he
took your advice thankfully luckily he
put his ego in check because there's
people that are like no I'm not leaving
it's on hell yeah that's how people end
up getting killed he had an eagle but he
also had a census saving his own
ass
uh uh fast forward a little bit here
again that's it but just you're just
dealing with like Mayhem I mean this is
just Mayhem yeah and you're just keeping
it together it's a 26 year old yeah
Lieutenant former Lieutenant JG yeah the
reason
they started calling me commander and I
thought okay I'll be fair enough why not
that made me equal to by the way
in terms of rank so that also worked it
was totally accidental but did you look
old for your age
or not really uh well you there's a
picture
you look like maybe yeah you don't look
like a full Commander though oh no no
way yeah uh fast forward a little bit
here you say I was back at base
monitoring the radio and I suddenly
heard Ricardo Chavez's voice shout
attack the distinct pop pop of machine
gun came crackling through the radio
immediately just distinguishable from
the mundane static and clutter my ear
was attuned to the prospect of a
firefight and the hair on my arms began
to prickle as that unmistakable sound
cut through the feeble reception of our
rudimentary equipment the Swifts were
out on the lake and in some the
only question was how deep the boat crew
opened fire with the first
semi-automatic Soviet AK-47 weapons we'd
capture captured in the previous raids
that was one of our ways we hurt them
using their own guns against them if the
boats got really close during the melee
of the firefight the AKs would come in
handy Lobo 1 was armed for combat
carrying 50 cal machine guns mounted a
midship sport starboard and aft plus a
shoulder-fired 57 millimeter recoilless
rifle on the gun tub above the cabin a
concussive barrage erupted as five enemy
vessels returned fire bullets screaming
between boats Toledo recalled the events
vividly as soon as we made contact one
boat separated from the group in
hindsight we realized it was obviously
to distract us leaving us to contend
with the other four boats that were
firing intensely
the fifth boat that cut away was
stationed a short distance behind the
others not firing a shop just waiting as
if trying to decide whether to re-engage
or depart then their decision made the
fifth boat suddenly swung around and
opened up again in a hail of bullets
that covered their escape As It sped
east across the black Waters toward the
enemy Refuge of Tanzania
I debriefed Chavez and it was clear to
both of us that there was something very
curious about that fifth boat the manner
in which it had escaped suggested it
sheltered someone or something very
important a VIP we thought otherwise the
remaining enemy boats would not have put
up such Fierce resistance their previous
Behavior had consistently been cut and
run
we had already discovered that Castro
Cubans were fighting alongside communist
rebels we had detected the radio calls
because they weren't disciplined enough
to protect their names or language they
blatantly violated even minimal tactical
cover on the radio and of course one
Cuban recognizes another so who had been
on that boat who had merited such Fierce
protection we believed it had to be Che
Guevara
it was reasonable to assume that it
would have taken someone of his stature
and importance of Che to motivate the
four boats to remain in the fight and to
sacrifice themselves in order to give
the fifth boat
protection so it could open up and
withdraw and Escape
and then you go out in here in guevara's
Diary the African Dream the Diaries of
the Revolution Revolutionary War in the
Congo he writes about the pressure he
and the rebels felt from the five
Commando ground troops and from the
Navy's interdiction efforts
by our daily patrols we had been a able
to nearly close down the rebel supply
lines which he created which created a
shortage of everything particularly food
we also made sure weapons ammunition
medicine could not reach their base
they were systematically being deprived
of everything they depended on as our
Navy began to live up to its
capabilities the battle strategy was
working exactly as we had planned and
prepared for we intensified patrolling
even more and as Chase diary indicates
the intimidation Factor we created kept
the captains of their vessels from even
attempting translate Supply missions as
supplies ran out the attrition rate
kicked up and toward the end of the
summer the simbas began deserting those
desertion numbers would escalate slowly
and then become a critical Exodus into
the fall campaign and you just posted up
with uh Che guevara's daughter here's
the African Dream the Diaries of the the
Revolutionary War in the Congo and then
the epilogue he makes other references
in the book but in the epilogue
uh what he's discussing the mercenaries
and the opposition Services he says
their weapons do not currently add up
this is he's writing to himself and to
Castro their weapons do not currently
add up too much the most telling have
been their PT boats which have made it
difficult to cross the lake blah blah
blah there you go it worked by his own
admission
um
yeah and you've got some you've got some
good quotes in here uh that you pulled
from
from there uh
guevara's Army suffered from a scarcity
of competent leadership and lack of
organization according to his writings
his group was continually outmaneuvered
by the five Commando mercenaries that he
refers to as Guardsmen
he says in that in that book I was
informed that a large number of
Guardsmen were out flanking us from the
hills only one unit did honor to our
army and resisted for another hour he
continues from a military point of view
the situation is difficult in that our
troops are collections of armed men
without the slightest discipline and
without fighting spirit
the CIA had built and fast forward a
little bit the CIA had built a massive
Air Force and the air campaign was
critical to our mission success a
training program that had begun as early
as 1961 at the request the Congolese
grew into a superb Air Force piloted
solely by Cuban exiles
and and you go into some of that but
that's another just awesome piece you
know the Cubans were willing to go out
and fight where they ever could wherever
they could against communism
and and they did
they were out there flying around
strafing troops and taking out their
boats I mean pretty awesome effort
um
and you say this here ultimately Che
seemed to recognize the futility of his
position and this is again from his
diary could I ask the Cubans to die in
the trenches to defend this piece of
nothing he questions
he then sent another message by radio to
to Fidel Castro things are falling apart
whole units and peasants are going over
to the enemy crew and boats in good
condition
urgently needed
Chase Calamity was nearly finished in
the Congo
well it was his his own arrogance and
ignorance
um
at the outset which led to this because
he really he did had did no assessment
of the environment he was coming into
and the people he thought he was going
to be working with he just thought he
was going to come in and make these
people ideologically committed and they
hadn't have they didn't know communism
from capitalism from you know whatever
utopianism to whatever
uh they wanted to
do what they'd always done which great
pillage and blunder
and I thought that he could turn them
into some kind of an ideological force
was this nonsense he he was a romantic
revolutionary in every sense of the word
he had uh he loved to kill
there's ample evidence of that and when
he wanted some practice he'd just go
into the prison in Havana
and he
it was all about his Zeal for quote the
Revolution and he couldn't build
anything which he proved when he was
minister of Industries in in Cuba he
wasn't a builder he was just a killer
just to kill her
[Music]
I'm gonna fast forward a little bit
um November 21st you talk about this
would have been the day that Guevara and
his men evacuated out of Tanzania
Che Guevara and his ill-fated Rebel band
had been out of food money weapons
supplies and luck we ran them out of the
Congo
they were sent packing by the combined
efforts of the force Naval Congolese and
the Mighty makassi air force and the
five Commando mercenary Army
but even with that portion of the rebels
forces on the runs are on the Run are
operations against the remaining
insurgents continued
the events in Congo begin to move
quickly after the Communist Q even
forces pulled out the same week on
November 25th General Mobutu stage of
bloodless coup d'etat which ousted
president kazavu and prime minister
Kimba
the coup also created internal Congolese
constitutional problems
and even though the U.S sought as a way
of preventing political and Military
disintegration Mobutu was only 35 years
old and the Constitution required a
minimum presidential age of 40 the
Constitution would have to be amended to
accommodate him
I've said that all of us in the Congo
believe that Mobutu was the best option
at the time he was comparatively
non-corrupt and demonstrated leadership
skills acknowledged his failures of his
own troops as a part of an effort to
upgrade its quality and performance and
showed no signs of seeking Revenge
retribution for any of anything in the
past
the corruption in megalomania that would
become the standard in his government
was not evident at this time in his
personal history
Lieutenant my core decides he's not
going to extend his contract so he's
done you got Mobutu taken over
um
you say this here at this point Lobo one
was the was only one nautical mile
offshore Chavez and the crew then
withdrew and took their Swift boats
another four miles out waited until dawn
through the course of the night began to
rain hard there was an absolutely no
visibility
and there were no longer longer any
night lights discernible at 4 AM they
began to patrol again searching for
lights as they had earlier they
patrolled that area for another two
hours but as the sun came up they lost
any chance of spotting those lights
again Chavez wrote how bright the lights
on the beach were
and then you say they waited still
hoping to see those lights when no
illumination were spotted on the shore
the crew headed south back to their
previous Target at the end of the
peninsula there they found clusters of
Lights in two groups when the crew was
ordered to make a high fire all the
lights in both groups suddenly went out
Chavez ordered the crew to fire again
and they found the enemy a rapid
exchange of gunfire erupted between the
boats and the enemy on the shore for
nearly an hour Chavez and his crew were
embroiled and shipped a short battle
using all weapons on board until Chavez
log finally records They Don't Shoot
anymore Lobo wanted taken out an enemy
stronghold they had been out of the lake
out on the lake for more than 24 hours
and had gauged in two serious gunfights
attacked on the water and from the shore
and these are all these are just
highlights that I'm hitting you give
really good details and you got the log
books from Chavez I mean it's it's
pretty awesome to read this stuff
in fact this is like one one of those
cool points you say when I began the
project of writing this book I opened
the ship's logbook for the first time in
years I found a note one page of lined
paper torn from a loose leaf binder
lying inside the front cover the note is
addressed to me I don't remember reading
it at the time but seeing it nearly half
century later written in a little bit of
phonetic Spanglish I found it a gracious
parting gift from the crew chief it says
we give you Goodyear
1966. employees of Force Navy kivu
Captain R Chavez
1 9 66. Ricardo and his men had indeed
handed me and all of us concerned
a Very Good Year
no no it's a treasure yeah that's that's
awesome to be able to find that
so as this stuff is kind of winding down
and we mentioned that my course kind of
done with his contract
and and you've got this
you know you got this story in here just
get the book to get this story but the
and you mentioned these guys earlier you
got this guy named John Peters who's one
of
you know top guys
um
and then you've got Cassidy
uh
and Peter's you say let me make sure I
get this right Peter's
had been responsible for securing
any of the resources five Commando had
taken during their raids Peters was an
ex-nco who is said to have a fanatical
prejudice against the British officer
class he was also ruthless killer may
have been a deserter from the British
army
and then on the so you got that guy you
got this guy John Peters and then you've
also got another guy named Von opin or
sorry van open
and Van oppen you say here was a
textbook perfect as a British officer
tall and handsome upper middle uh Upper
Crust British accent had attended the
Royal Military Academy at Sandhurst he
got court-martialed because of something
that happened like something got stolen
and he ends up
uh not graduating but he ends up
fighting in Korea he ends up fighting in
Egypt then he serves in the federal army
in in Rhodesia
and basically you go through this whole
story it's just fascinating to read
about
um these guys are basically in
competition for who's going to take over
as leaders of the five Commando correct
and one of them ends up dead
um van often ends up dead with a bunch
of bullets in his stomach and
self-inflicted allegedly a click I mean
a clip a whole clip self-inflicted tough
guy
[Laughter]
uh you know it's it's wild you know
because a lot of this stuff you know
growing up I was always fascinated with
the military you know I was fascinated
with anyone you know the mercenaries
Soldier of Fortune like all this stuff
was part of my childhood you know the
movies
and so when you you like kind of know
these names like I did I mean I've
always known about about my core you
know he's this famous guy and five
Commando you know about these things
that you know about the rhodesians and
you know the recruiting that happened
with the rhodesians to bring British
military down there and uh just like the
Rhodesian Commandos like all those
things
that that all you you said so much light
on those things and it's it's wild for
me to think about because every time I
think about my core I'm like no you were
actually you you worked with this guy
yeah how long were you there for a total
a little less than a year so this is a
guy you worked with like directly and
and and all these first crazy mercenary
Killers When crazy mercenary Killers was
a thing because listen there's a modern
day version of a mercenary you know that
goes out and does security and they're
working for the government and they're
getting hired by one of these big
contractors and look there's been some
flare-ups there's been some things that
have happened that are certainly have
been investigated and some people been
punished I I don't have a lot of details
about that but but basically it's a much
more
common thing that oh this guy retired
from the Marine Corps went to work for
this company he's going overseas his
contractor yeah
that's not the same thing that's just
not the same thing as what these guys
were these guys are legit mercenaries
right and this is your day-to-day
interactions and you built the Navy with
these guys oh it's wild to read
um
uh
going back to the book here and you
mentioned this earlier but it was a
cruel element of Fate that came into our
world on the afternoon of November 28th
it would take a major toll on our crew
about six o'clock in the evening a young
Congolese corporal
was driving a poorly maintained truck
down this military transport Road
and with no warning the truck sputtered
and stopped stalling directly in front
of the bar calamay
just near the bada bada boot store and a
few hundred meters north of the hotel to
lock that's where you guys lived the
Vada boot store was the only store in
Albertville that had glass in the
windows
[Laughter]
yeah so this truck breaks down
um
and and it just doesn't move
and so it's a Sunday evening a new moon
had just occurred
so at 1 35 a.m on Monday it was Pitch
Black African night on the deserted
street with a five ton Hazard laying in
weight there was no caution lights on
the truck no reflectors nothing that
would Mark the presence of an enormous
vehicle abandoned on a dark dry Road in
the middle of the night a pair of five
Commando mercenary soldiers from South
Africa Hans Von Leer's
and Cornelius johans Von week had been
out together that night Gooch was with
them
the three of them had driven that road
many times and knew the terrain very
well
Von liers was behind the wheel and Gooch
was in the shotgun seat van wyk was
riding in the back
in the Blackness of the African night
with the driver feeling sure of himself
the Jeep came racing down that road at a
high rate of speed the official accident
report states that the Jeep slammed full
force into the back of the transport
truck thrusting the truck forward and
embedding its front bumper solidly into
a coconut palm
man there is Lay half inside and half
outside the GPU still alive when the
first witness ran to the scene the other
South African van wyk was also still
alive and was quickly taken to the
hospital for treatment
Gooch was killed instantly
I was not informed about the incident
about the accident until the next
morning when I got the news I was
immediately I went immediately to where
his body had been placed Cassidy came
with me from the source that is now lost
to memory we found wood and materials
and hammered together a coffin
with the assistance of Chavez prosciardo
and Papo we wrapped in a strong heavy
canvas and transported it down to the
port where we somehow managed to get a
refrigeration unit in one of the
warehouses working we made sure that
Gucci's body was held appropriately
until a plane could get it to
Albertville to make the transport to
leopoldville
there could be properly prepared for the
onward trip back to the USA
Gooch was certainly not the first
casualty had dealt with
but he was the one that affected me the
most having to handle his body with
respect in those extremely crude
circumstances was most disheartening it
was my Challenge and my responsibility
and we did our best in that terrible
situation to get our friend and
comrade's body back safely to his family
his contribution to our mission had been
essential
I've carried guilt around for 50 years
for old bang my instructions from the
agency not to speak with his wife at the
time
in retrospect in retrospect it was an
exaggerated security concern by the
agency
I'm hoping that this book will
adequately say what I would have said
all those years ago
the Goff family children remember the
day
well when they heard the news they
arrived home from school and some family
friends were there
a priest father alphon Alphonse Olive
who is also a family friend was there he
took the children to the bedroom and
told them what happened it was a very
difficult time for the family
they were not able to get a lot of
information from the agency about the
circumstances of Gooch's death youngest
son Nat was the one who eventually did
the research years later trying to fit
all the pieces together
Marcel Renee Goff Gooch to us was buried
at an Arlington National Cemetery on
December 6 1965. he was just 41 years
old
his son Mickey who is known as little
Gooch remembers that many of his
father's UDT and EOD mates were at
Arlington that day for the funeral
one of his most Vivid memories of the
casket he describes it as being made of
dark tropical wood
it was a small piece of the Congo that
went with Gooch and then onto his final
rest
his name is also inscribed on the
memorial wall at the Navy sealed museum
in Fort Pierce Florida where it belongs
and also
you you mentioned this or later in the
book in 2016
they added a gold star to the CIA
memorial wall at their headquarters in
Langley
Virginia in honor of Gucci's sacrifice
hell of a guy
when did you you said you met we finally
met the family
around the time this book came out
what they do afterwards
uh she worked at the CIA and you know
whatever
they uh they uh I think we if I remember
correctly we met in 2014 we had the 50th
commemoration of the hostage rescue at
Stanleyville which was the the Prelude
of this of this book and that was a
large I think the largest Rescue of
American hostages in history at least up
to that time
and five Commando gets the credit for
the rescue but it was really a Cubans
led by an american guy named Rip
Robertson C.I paramilitary I got there
first
um
there's a on the cover of Paris match
magazine and
sometime in 65 or 66 65 sorry 64. damn
it come on Jim
um
there's a picture of the swarthy guy
who she didn't know was Cuban holding
this little blue blonde I heard blew out
four-year-old girl
uh with a machine gun in his other hand
uh and she and
a whole bunch of the other people who
are rescued
including four of the five sons of the
American missionary who was murdered at
km8
kilometer eight outside of Stanleyville
two of the sons were were wounded but
not severely
and that during that rescue period they
four of those five sons and all these
other people including this little girl
and not a little girl any longer
obviously 50 years later all came to
Miami to the commemoration
because none of them are met the people
who rescued them
it was very moving you can imagine for
sure yeah this you know she they've
never met the people who would save
their lives and these four Americans are
I guess they're Americans they've been
born and raised in the God where their
dad was died they're still in the Congo
doing the Lord's work
the amazing guys anyway these people all
came
the only coverage the only coverage was
Miami uh
TV station uh gee what's the guy's name
he's been a real friend of the community
um
for this very moving event I mean you
know these all these people whose lives
were were saved both Americans and
of other nationalities not not counting
all the Congolese
and that's one of the reasons I wanted
to write this because the Cubans are
never given been given any recognition
for what they did this is it
uh and uh
you know it's it's it's it's just
outrageous in my mind and none of those
Cuban politicians have gotten off their
butts and done anything about it in
Florida either which I cannot understand
um but anyway
that was a very moving event that 50th
commemoration wow
all those people there to say thanks for
coming from all around the world and we
couldn't even get anybody from
Washington DC
figures
um but fast forward a little bit here
that you know you you got more fighting
with the rebels you're beating the
Rebels the the Cuban Sailors are start
to kind of turning over with the locals
and with the five Commando
and just to close out this part part of
the book you say here with my Cuban crew
gone and missions winding down it was
finally time for me to pack up and leave
Congo
I did so exactly how as I had arrived
quietly
I boarded the c-46 in Albertville with
my three pairs of khaki pants three
Safari shirts
and a pair of desert boots
and and that was that that was uh
um
how was so what'd you do when you got
back
how was your transition back to the
world well uh
well like you know when you're when
you're when you're you know very well
when you're working with that
amount of adrenaline constant constantly
pumping into your system it it takes a
while to come down
you know you you miss it it's it's it's
item never done a drug in my life but I
can't imagine it can be any more
um
addictive and then that degree of uh
of adrenaline constantly
being injected into your system
so
I
I met a lady in uh
in leopoldville she worked at the
embassy there
and she was and so I I kind of
chased her around for a little while and
uh
um
tried to figure out what I really wanted
what I was going to do next they by this
time the agency decided they wanted me
to go into the Career Training Program
um
and I I really liked what I'd been done
and I liked the people that I'd worked
with I mean how you know how can you be
first you deal with seals and then you
deal with the best guys they got in the
agency I mean that's a that's a hell of
a run
with an incredible amount of autonomy as
a 26 year old yeah freaking run in a war
in the Congo exactly well then I what I
would oh I remember now what I was going
to do I want to go to Laos
there might have been the only God only
guy in the sort of
special ops Community who had done
Vietnam Congo and Laos
Whoopi I mean today anyway at the time
that would be fun to do well I got
conned
by the best
who basically said okay you can be a
knuckle tracker all your life where you
can really get into the
into the tough stuff and he wanted me to
be a strictly a foreign intelligent he
used to be an intelligence
be a case officer
so uh and I and so I went into the uh I
went into the Career Training Program
got all the
all the training which was terrific
and then uh at the end of that
uh
you you basically gonna I didn't want to
go in the embassy I didn't want anything
to do with the embassy
and of course that's the career path in
the in in the agency you've got to
really got to be in the you've got to be
in the embassy because that's where most
case officers are
and I said no that's not for me and they
said well might as well be a
non-official cover
and I said
you'll be all alone and I said sounds
great and so uh so they fixed me up with
a cover that was illegal in the country
that I went to
so I had said my own cover which meant
starting a business
and that worked out well it provided a
good cover and the business was afforded
me
a way of enhancing my
ability to collect the kind of
intelligence they were interested at the
time this was in Southeast Asia so
Vietnam was hot you know what year is
this 1965. this is 68 60. 67 67 68 69.
and um
so the country that I went to was
hostile at the time
and so that was pretty exciting uh doing
some interesting stuff and then the
country went our way they just opted for
the West it was it was a it was a
Battleground Country from the Communist
Center or from the West it went our way
so now I just got bored
I mean I just got bored it was it was
was there any other countries they put
on the plate for you well then there
would have been uh where you were born
but I was bored I had a we had a
personal problem I had to deal with and
it required some professional help and
couldn't get it anywhere else
and I had
really liked starting that business
um and so I fired off an application to
Harvard Business School figuring you
know at the time it's not like that
today I don't think but at the time they
were interested in screwball too you had
sort of under different kind of
backgrounds
and I thought well you know I'm happy
doing what I I like I got no complaints
I'm having known if I can get to our
business school I'll go otherwise I'll
keep doing what I'm doing it's this is
not bad
and um
I got in and uh so I fired off a
resignation which shocked everybody
because again I didn't have any
complaints I've been well treated they
said
quote there was the words were shocked
and dismayed and I said
hey what can I say I got no complaints
this has been great I'm just going to do
something else
so that was it
that was it I went to business school
went back went back to Asia for the next
35 years and what were you doing what
kind of businesses were you oh well we
were first thing I did was I was in
charge of building the the first
Sheraton in Asia which was the Hong Kong
Sheraton
and I met this guy in Atlanta who's
the most remarkable business guy I've
ever worked with and it was terrible to
start with him because I thought this is
what business was going to be like and I
never met another one like it but in a
way he was kind of like Dick Johnson he
you know you see once he made up once he
made a decision on you that was it he
just backed you to the hill
so with two weeks of real estate
experience one week in his office in one
week at the travel Crow company in
Dallas which was the number one real
estate company in the whole country at
the time I went out he took me out to
Hong Kong said this is Jim Halsey speaks
for me he left
and it was the deepest hole in Hong Kong
at the time it was uh
the financing was not in place it was on
the tail end of the cultural revolution
so people in all Congress were still
looking for the exit because they didn't
know
what was going to happen whatever it is
50 years later was gonna might happen
then right
and uh so he basically said figure it
out so
I'd had some experience at that so it
was okay I mean I didn't really didn't
know much he didn't there was Talent
around new real estate it was sort of
how to get it all all put together
and my deal and that was a handshake I
worked for Mighty low wages for a
project that was the biggest most
glamorous project in Hong Kong and I was
basically working for peanuts
but the deal was that he'd give me a
steak on my own because he correctly
said when we first got acquainted he
said look I know what you're like you're
going to want to go on your own and
that's fine just promise me we'll do a
deal together so that was it was a
handshake this guy was I told you I
never met anyone like it in the business
World anyway his personal life was a
shambles but his professional life was
absolutely perfect and the guy was just
behaved perfectly in business
and uh which defies the usual you know
the usual rule that people have about
that anyway
um so the Sheraton was and we in in
Hong Kong the culture Revolution was was
ending and Hong Kong was starting to
come back because it was such a such
incredibly resilient and energetic place
with all those Chinese entrepreneurs
and uh
so the project was going good so I
called him and I said well I'm ready to
I'm ready to uh
to do my own deal
there was kind of a silence and he said
okay let me know what you want to do so
I go back to Indonesia dumbass that I am
because
I hear I've done the most glamorous
project in Hong Kong
so what do I do I leave to go back to go
back to Indonesia well I got lucky on
Indonesia because the offshore industry
was just starting there was no Office
Space
and I created the first Office Park in
Indonesia which was
which is as close as I can make it to
Perimeter Office Park in Atlanta Georgia
in fact I went into them said I'd like
to do this in Indonesia can have a set
of your plans
I said well I guess we'll never do
anything in Indonesia yeah here so he
gave me a set of the plans and modified
them and milk it and and did this Office
Park in Jakarta which was a roaring
success which is exactly when I should
have quit except at this point I thought
I was a hell of a businessman I thought
I was a hell of a businessman
anyway
um so I stayed in Indonesia for a while
and did some more stuff in Indonesia and
by this time we had a had one we had one
daughter and another one on the way and
my wife had trouble carrying so I had to
be near the right kind of medical
facilities there were none in Indonesia
so we moved to Singapore stayed in
Singapore for the next I don't know 10
or 12 years or whatever
and had huge successes and huge failures
I went up and down like a yo-yo
and uh so I I've basically been
connected with Asia ever since and we
started first Venture Capital firm and
which was based in Hong Kong
with the grand capital
fund of two million dollars
mostly passed in the Hat to people
around and about and that that
brought me for the first McDonald's to
Asia
which of course was a roaring success it
made us all look better than we were
and um
they did a number of other things first
Decay is in Asia the first McDonald's in
Asia for sure in Asia it's a great time
to be there great time to be there
and the thing I loved about southeast
Asia is it was kind of like going
through SEAL training nobody knew who
your daddy was nobody cared it was all
all on you you've made your own
reputation that was that was good with
me and then you know then the American
lawyers and the American Banks started
coming in and screwing it up but yeah it
was the best time in the history of the
world to be there
since then I've just since then I've
just done stuff uh you know business
things after entrepreneurial type things
but you spent the last few years in
Africa is that right yes and what were
you doing there this time well when I
when I allegedly when I was I was when I
was in Burma on a
two-month Consulting gig that turned out
to be a year
friend of mine had taken over CEO CEO of
the first of the biggest bank in Burma
and mentored to the daughters of the
owner I I I'm really a remarkable guy he
is um and he said come on take a look
around because they had 450 branches and
Scattered throughout Burma or myanmars
it's known today
and about half of them are out there in
the boonies where they're 31 to 33
dissonant armies depending on Whose
drugs are moving that day and so and
everything was Cash 95 of that economy
is Cash was cash so they had some
security concerns and my My Pal came you
know my friend had done some stuff with
in China years before
uh said
come on out and have a look around we
hit for a couple months I said sure well
that turned out to be a year and during
that year the the military did their
coup
so it was becoming a little less
inviting for for people with our kind of
a background and about this time about
this time I get a call from Africa and
Congo says are you interested in doing a
um
a
surveillance program in the Gulf of
Guinea because the locus of of
kidnapping and and piracy and so forth
that was shifting from Horn of Africa to
the Gulf of Guinea
and I said no I'm not interested in a
surveillance program I said you can get
a radar you guys thanks rape
surveillance is Radars you can get a
radar manufacturer
we'll be glad to flogging some Raiders
half-assed trainer people and disappear
I'm not interested in that
so if you're interested in a
comprehensive solution I I uh I'd be
interested I said well what's that and I
said well I'll write it up for you and
send you a powerpoint and I had to do
with detection surveillance detection
Institute reliable Communications rapid
reaction force blah blah blah
none of which any of them had
and they said oh we like this so
I said okay uh
I'll come but let's get one thing
straight I'm too old to run away from
the IRS
in y'all's reputation as you're doing
not mine so anything I do I'm going to
be able to sign with the U.S company the
LLC and a U.S bank account oh God don't
worry no problem no problem
look these places are as corrupt as
Washington okay you're terrible and and
so I've been the last three years
working on those in several countries
and it looks like it's going to happen
I hope it's going to happen because it's
a worthy it's a worthy way to go out uh
Eastern Congo is where 75 percent of the
rare earth minerals come from and it's
actually slavery I mean it is real life
so I'm not exaggerating it's slavery
it's terrible
and um
uh they're more it's it's a worse it's
distinguishing is hardly worth doing but
it's arguably worse than the Ukraine
and uh
you know periodically the Western
moisturizers and Western countries
sitting on a training team and blah and
they go around but you know they're out
in the terrain it's got no roads or if
they do they're in paths are impassable
for most of the year
uh and so how do they how do the how do
people move around well they move around
in the rivers the bad guys move around
in the rivers the good guys don't they
don't have a very capability
and and all the locals move around the
river so I see you know I finally met
this Minister and I said minister
you know I said number one you the only
way you know what's going on out there
is if you get in a plane with your staff
and you fly out there and then you got
to find them on impassable roads
um and then when you find them
you've got no maneuverability and you
don't have any way of finding out what
you did what happened after you got
there you said you got to have Community
instant Communications
which are available if you know how to
access them I said you got to have a
riverine capability because that's how
the bad guys move
uh so you gotta have a rapid reaction
force and you've got to have the right
kind of equipment you have to have the
right kind of trading and
here's the package
and they all say they want to do it and
a a
critical part of who's been figuring out
to get them financed and I think we got
that I think we got that figured out so
so we're getting Mighty close but I hate
to say we're doing it because you know
you're not doing it until you're doing
it but we're we're Mighty close and
that's what I've been working on it's
about four countries
still got a lot of stuff going on
the only way to go
um
I know it's interesting too and just
going back to the book here for a second
you know the way this all turned out
uh government corruption of course
allowed many ideas many of the riches of
the Congo to be exported it was a
country with deep reserves of copper
Cobalt uranium and diamonds 1971 Mobutu
renamed the con the country Zaire
uh diamonds ended up surpassing
everything as a Congo's main export
including Cobalt and copper diamonds
made made up 30 percent of the country's
total exports in 1989 but through
corruption and financial mismanagement
the entire mining industry was in
Jeopardy and its share of the GDP went
from 11.3 percent in 1988 to 4.7 1994
mobudu's ill-conceived fiscal programs
drove the country from bad to worse as
the years wore on even as his personal
Fortune soared over his 32-year Reign he
was estimated to be worth as much as 5
billion dollars while almost all facets
of life in Congo deteriorated he
maintained a presidential Services fund
that took up between 17 and 20 percent
of the government's budget
he owned personal stock in every
Enterprise relating to Zaire and Congo
and it was said that no business
transaction with a foreign owned company
was allowed to take place unless a
kickback was paid to Mobutu personally
he was the largest shareholder in the
Bank of of consosha and had personal
ownership either partial or outright in
agricultural businesses Mining and
Manufacturing in all provinces of the
country but as Mobutu and his family
members and hand-picked cronies grew
wealthier the country fell to near ruin
the highway road and rail systems were
in utter disrepair the Health Care
System wasn't funded human rights
violations were rampant
just a few years before Mobutu would
finally leave the scene according to the
same Harvard study the country faced a
risk of virtual disintegration due to
hyperinflation the GDP plummeted pushing
the economy into substance agriculture
by the end of 1995 income per capita was
only one-third its pre-independence
levels
Mobutu got forced out of power in 1997
he died in Exile a year after that
um Lauren kabila took over I was in I
was in Sierra Leone in 1998 as the war
was going off and things were getting
crazy again in the Congo the echo MOG
was down there working
um
but it sounds like you're back there now
at least trying to make make a positive
impact
yeah four different countries
standing yeah
um what else do we get every is that it
we up to speed are we up to present day
I think we're pretty close
Echo you got any questions
this is going to seem out of nowhere but
how's Singapore right now is a place to
live
I was in Singapore when anywhere and
declared independence right after that
because I went down from Vietnam before
you were allowed to go to Singapore from
Vietnam
and uh
it was so I've seen the whole the whole
transition the whole growth I'm
remarkable remarkable what can be done
when the corruption is at an absolute
minimum and you got everybody focused
with a strong leader
uh Singapore is
the garden spot just a garden spot it's
now expensive and they're now they're
they're now they have a bit of a social
problem and that they've it's just
gotten so expensive they got to do you
gotta do something to keep the
Spark
uh is spark going which was
but yes they uh leak on you uh
was uh it was a multi-racial with all
the with all the I mean just the next
door in Malaysia there's always the
Chinese Malay problem they wouldn't none
of that in Singapore
the Indian Community in Singapore was
was
small comparatively small but extremely
uh
important
and Lee Kuan Yew was able to take this
team of Chinese Indians and
and a couple of malays and Lead that
growth
no corruption tolerated
and
unleash the entrepreneurial spirit
uh
within the rules
and it's just been an extraordinary to
watch it just extremely am I new to
those guys I mean I knew this you know
so many of his old teams and that's what
so remember you know I I can remember
when they did the classic thing and came
the Garment garments guys because that's
where they had to get people employed
what he did what he did
was he gave everybody a stake in success
of Singapore by by making sure everybody
was an owner of their own residence now
in doing that he had to get rid of the
traditional Villages which caused you
know a lot of people in the west yeah
just remember when all this was going on
and you guys were having to read the New
York Times in the Washington Post
I was I was out there and I was reading
the Bangkok Post
and straight in the Singapore Straits
times and your Carter Post in the
Malaysian times
all different stuff okay
um so he uh I can remember I can
remember when
at the start of it all once a year Lee
Kuan Yew would pick out an expatriate
business leader
and hang him I'm not not literally
hanging but you know you just would have
assumed that he was up to something and
make a new example okay was that fair
and good he generally picked the right
guys okay
I remember how significant was the first
time he picked a Chinese business leader
to make an example of it was you know
that was because it reflected actually
what was happening in this in the
society the Chinese were solely taking
over everything that it had previously
been Colonial or whatever
um yeah that started out with a factory
you know just the factory the Garment
workers I remember how it embarrassed
they were
in Singapore when when they had an
outbreak of uh Coro and as Cora was
supposed was a uh was a group hysteria
in which the the the men were afraid
that their that their scrotums were
ascending into their lower abdomen and
they were getting they got hysterical
this happened in factories and they had
a name for it I think it was Koro if I
remember correctly and dealing with all
that kind of stuff and I mean they went
through the whole whole thing except
they went through it with a guy who was
who was adamant against corruption and
uh was focused on on success and what
was good for Singapore
and the U.S the US didn't make it easy
for him early on in the early days
because they considered him a socialist
and when I take a look around at the
guys
go back to that headquarters thing
we never listened to the guys who worked
with Ho Chi Minh during the second world
war never paid any attention to Ho Chi
Minh was the Communist okay man wanted
to be successful in Hong Kong in La
mumba
looking for friends we weren't going to
be his friend because the belgians
didn't like him and therefore and we
couldn't like him so he goes to the go
to go to Russia when I did them was
doing the research for this I was all
starting off with a set what I'd always
thought about remember I was going to
the conclusion my mother was not a
hardcore communist he was just looking
for friends and where he could get the
money to help him do what he was trying
to do
uh Lee Kuan Yew uh Socialism or you
wasn't a socialist he understood what he
is he understood his people you know he
understood what it would take to grow
and he would listen he got this Dutch
economic guy Economist and the two of
them together put the master plan for
what has become Singapore and then not
only that he voluntarily stepped down
I mean tell me how many dictators have
done that anywhere any continent
so
uh anyway that starts with kind of a
wordy answer to your question it's a
great place I lived there for 15 or 20
years yeah
Jim any other any other closing thoughts
term limits
I support him
meritocracy I support it
awesome uh well you know before closing
out I just wanted to go to the book one
last time I want to you gave a speech at
a reunion to honor those that had fought
in the Congo the Americans the Cubans
the belgians I think this was 2014 yeah
that was the 50th commemoration and um
here's what you said about these men and
I'm just going to read the next Republic
you said these men These Fine men
will receive no recognition no medals no
rose garden thanks
they've always known that is the way it
would be
and they have never asked for more what
they will have that no one can ever deny
them is the respect admiration and
affection of those who were there and
who and who truly know how bravely and
honorably these men performed and of
course the Gratitude from those who are
saved what these men had was each other
their Mutual trust respect their pride
in their performance and their
dedication to the eradication of
communism
there were no expressions of entitlement
and there are still none
they took the conditions circumstances
and threats that were presented and did
what they were tasked with accomplishing
they were disciplined and proud
participants in a historical event
saving thousands of lives including
those we are privileged to have with us
here today in their desire to salute
their Rescuers
it is no exaggeration to say that these
folks would not have survived that
Terror without the intervention and
performance of these men
50 years later there are lessons in
these events relevant to today's war on
terror
it takes dedicated men of intelligence
judgment and courage willing to go into
Harm's Way to do the job to protect the
lives of the innocent and to destroy
those of perverted political and
religious beliefs who seek to harm us
please join me and salute these
deserving men
well sir we
salute these Heroes for sure and I'm
glad we can tell their story and salute
you for your service and and thank you
sir for what you did for the teams
and what you did for our country and for
the cause of freedom in the world thank
you thank you for what you do thank you
for what you did thank you what you do
and what you're going to continue to do
and I really appreciate this because not
enough people know about these guys
well we're telling them now amen thanks
sir appreciate it thank you
and with that Jim Hoss has left the
building
definitely
pretty awesome conversation 20 you go
back to that 26 years old
being in the Congo by yourself working
with random mercenaries and foreign
Nationals
and and putting together
to fight a war against
insurgents
that's pretty awesome and it's pretty
awesome he kept referring back to
the training right yeah and I think
that's such a huge part and he he
mentioned Ben Milligan I'll mention Ben
Milligan as well in that book in in Ben
Milligan's book
uh by by water beneath the walls
you know he he ties that route back into
the U.S Navy and the Navy in general and
how when you're out on a ship by
yourself in the middle of nowhere you
got to make things happen yeah it's
decentralized command so this is an
incredible example of decentralized
command for a 26 year old Lieutenant
Junior gray in the U.S Navy to roll out
and run a
yeah
of a counterinsurgency in a different
country so very cool lots of things
going on uh definitely appreciate it I
also obviously love hearing some of
those old stories about what
training was like when he sent me some a
little bit of a bio he said you know
class 29 e and then he had in
parentheses winter he wanted to let me
know that it was a winter yeah hell week
if you talk about the snow and
everything but yeah that stuff's pretty
cool is that that's a big difference
though right the winter versus because
you guys talk about that here or at the
end of the day is it just hard hard it's
hard hard let's face it
it's a little bit colder yeah it's a
little bit colder you know what I'm
saying I think my hell week was like a
spring hell week yeah it was like a
spring hell week and that's still cold
right Coronado oh yeah I mean it
definitely was cold I mean you're gonna
be cold but it wasn't 37 degrees which
in a winter hell week out here can be
37 degrees 41 degrees Yeah they and and
listen there's some different suffering
that happens in the summertime yeah
because you're hotter and being hot
sucks and and I guess in the winter in
the summertime you're more swollen and
more chafed
so you know pick your poison yeah but I
think you gotta if you just run the
numbers yeah more people quit now a week
during the winter time yeah I think if
you just run the numbers you I can't sit
here and defend it I can't be like well
you know it's just as hard no if you run
the numbers you're gonna find winter
hell week less survivors
and East Coast winter hell week snow on
the ground
yeah that's yeah you know some people
are quitting you know when you see that
snow yeah he mentioned that where it's
like hey fall down in the snow like damn
that's a just psychologically right out
the gate the interesting thing is
they're gonna get you yeah they're gonna
get you and they're gonna make you
they're gonna push you to your physical
limit
you like how many push-ups can you do
right now if I dropped you down and said
I want you to do as many push-ups as you
can if you give me a minute and a half
to like stretch out okay yep you got
that minute half to stretch out how many
are you gonna get solid probably 120
maybe okay so you do 120 push-ups
and then what are you gonna do when I
tell you keep going
lay down like by the way how long would
it take you to do 120 push-ups
140 seconds 120 seconds okay so two
minutes so let's say I drop you down you
do two minutes worth of push-ups yeah
two minutes we have 14 more hours to
kill in this day first first phase of
buds right like you could exhaust
yourself in every exercise and guess
what you're gonna keep going yep we
gotta keep going yeah that's that's so
so you're gonna reach your physical
limitation you're gonna reach your
mental limitation when you you freak out
about stuff and stress and all this
stuff so they're gonna get you gonna be
37 degrees it might be 45 degrees it
might be 52 degrees Yeah but they're
gonna get you they're going to get a
bunch of people to quit
so the cool thing is you learn that
adaptability and you learn how to make
things happen which is what uh Jim Haas
put to put to use yeah in Vietnam and
then over in the Congo
the drock the Democrat Democratic
Republic of the Congo
um
So speaking of things going on
we all have a lot of things going on you
should hopefully we're trying to have a
lot of things going on you need to fuel
that get yourself some Jocko fuel I I
just drank two
Jocko goes
what's cool is
it feels so good and I'm gonna feel good
yeah I'm gonna feel good there's no not
gonna be a crash not in two hours I'm
not gonna be coiled up watching a
Netflix series
in fact I'm going to be training in a
little while no Dave you know all right
so that's what we're doing that's what
we're getting after uh jockoffuel.com go
check that out we got we got ready to by
the way once when when Jim left the
building Jocko grabbed them okay I
grabbed an RTD no ready to drink milk
protein
um get yourself some of that we're in a
bunch of stores around the world all
around the country right now we're in
vitamin shop number one brand in vitamin
shop be aware of that uh yes I am I saw
that process go down good to be
um military commissars were in there
we're in Hannaford we're in dash stores
we're in Wake foreign
[Music]
where it's crushing we I was just in
Texas they have the big uh they call it
an end cap in the industry and what that
means is you don't have an aisle in the
grocery store and at the end of the
aisle there's could be some product
there they have a whole
end cap that whole end is just Jocko
fuel stuff yeah powder pow pow pop yeah
yeah it's good because all these things
like um you know when you couldn't kind
of compare it to others and all this
stuff where because I'll
I have been guilty of this in the past
distant past where man I need like an
energy drink or even like one of these
little ready to drink proteins or
whatever
and Brad just ignore the amount of sugar
in there I'm just gonna ignore that
because man I'm on the go you know I'm
leaving and what all kinds of excuses
that are just rtes ready to excuse
and the thing is that is factually true
where I'm like hey man maybe I'm going
into catabolic breakdown or something
like this so I do need that protein or
whatever sure I could you know so I'll
get the you know these other I don't
want to name anything you know throw
nobody under the bus but you do get
these ready to drink protein yeah no gas
stations we'll say gas station or a
7-Eleven something like this and yeah
like you see if you dare to look at the
sugar or these other things Hey listen
honestly if you remotely care about your
health yeah and you look at the sugar
you're putting it back yeah look if I'm
guilty of that I won't I'm not even
looking you know what I mean and I know
it's just a lie yeah it's once you look
and you go oh 36 grams of sugar
uh serving size one servings per
container two so you're about to ingest
72 grams of sugar this that doesn't make
up for being catabolic that protein is
not worth it it's not worth what are you
doing to your insulin levels and it's
true Brad so
in a situation like that this is how it
used to be for me where hey man I'll
just pay that price just today look I'm
not doing it every day just today I'll
pay that price and you so you pay you
pay that price like of course you pay
the price for the for the product you
know at the register yeah but come on
that price is going with you down the
street you see I'm saying bruh not
anymore man bro I'll grab two of those
whatever 60 grams of protein I grounded
yesterday I pounded two this is back to
back just got it done yeah banana banana
yep no no additional cost of your your
conscience no at all to clean just clean
fuel clean fuel jockle fuel by the way
listen time more this is something
here's my here's my anecdotal story
I went
to the muster at the muster you have
those down stage monitors they are a
certain size when I look so you were
standing on stage and you look down to
see what the notes are
and listen I've been blessed knock on
wood without my vision's always been
good
and like a lot of people my age my
friends they have glasses like they wear
eyeglasses to read or they wear
eyeglasses to look far or whatever I've
been very very lucky
but you know sometimes you like
especially if my eyes get a little tired
like I read a bunch sometimes it's sort
of notice or something I'm like what is
this
and so I was at the monster and I'm like
hey did we get bigger downstage monitors
and Wes is like no it's the same size
and I said oh are you using a bigger
font he's like no that's the standard
and I was like oh
I can see more clearly why is that
there's only one variable that's changed
time War
and we have ocular nutrition in there
so yeah that's like one small element
but I'll tell you it's not even a small
element
I will never I will take I will take
time more for the rest of my life right
now like a hundred percent just off that
right there that's just incredible
and to know that you're fueling your
body and keeping it in in on the path
this freaking epic so get time War try
it out let me know what you think I
think it's freaking legit
so uh there you go chocolate fuel.com
check it out yeah that mix of time work
because it has a lot of stuff in there
like even vitamins minerals all the all
the in the anti-aging stuff or whatever
it's funny so it mixed like that right
where it's not like uh
you know when you drink a coffee you
know it's like I know what the coffee's
gonna do to make me feel more alert
awake whatever all that stuff or
whatever but a mix like that it's funny
how all the little cracks in your
performance capability like the little
teeny tiny stuff like whether it be your
vision whether it be just a little ache
whether it be like um
you've fallen asleep faster or when you
wake up like certain like just things
that you just took for granted because
they don't like go down as smoothly uh
I'm telling you with time Wars is
another thing that I am noticing is like
a higher
consistent
I don't want to call it energy but
there's like a higher it is an energy
but it's not like a spike of energy it's
like oh I just feel more better more
better yeah yeah make that make that
thing more better yeah make that the
slogan you you feel like oh like I'll be
let's call it
let's call it 7 47 in the morning sure
workouts done
and sometimes in the past I'd be you
know 747 is kind of a little little low
you know what I mean like kind of tired
went for it worked out went for a run
feeling a little feeling a little bit of
a a downturn yeah and right now I'm like
feel good and real good yeah keep it
going again what's the what's the what's
the change
just one change time more anyways
freaking awesome check it out time War
jockoffool.com
also
originusa.com this is where you can get
your jeans American-made stuff this is
not just jeans obviously but all
American made from the cotton grown yeah
in the fields to the manufacturing to
the even the little buttons on there
everything made in America that's a big
whatever bro they did they're trying to
trick you these other brands like so a
lot of them they'll be like oh yeah I
made in America yeah some sometimes they
make those buttons yeah is there how
many teas are in button two how many do
I say zero zero button button no no
silent uh double silent two teeth but
you know you say button
but either way sometimes unless we want
those buttons made in America the whole
gig and if you're down for that that's
how originusa.com well a lot of good
stuff on there geez on there too yeah by
the way yeah Nano we visit Pearl Nano
weave is a nanopro
yeah yeah see that one's legit so I took
mine home yesterday yep yep yeah and I
have my old def key I made the little
comparison let's make it why is that fun
I feel you I feel the upgrade yeah it's
good that's a good one man originusa.com
go get some there you go yep it's true
also Jacob's doors called Jocko store
this is where you can get your
discipline equals freedom sure tatts
hoodies if you're representing on this
path and we're on the path
you'd be crazy not to be in this day and
age with all this good guidance there's
a lot of negativity actually is a more
important reason to be on what we're
calling the path what is known as the
path I noticed that the other day what's
weird is
I noticed the other day so listen I'm
not you know some people like hey you're
gonna bring more positivity in your life
like those kind of things watch out for
negativity and give me some more of
those little sayings like uh negative
people cut them away like all those kind
of things I I've heard that a lot in my
life and I've always not thought much of
it it didn't really mean much to me yeah
you know to me it was like oh you got to
stay positive I didn't even think that
was a thing yeah
but I don't know there's something like
in the last week
where I it was like I saw a bunch of
negative things uh for all in a very
short pretty film I was like oh that's
what people mean and you could get
sucked into that negativity yeah and it
didn't really make sense to me before
because it's never really been a
Temptation for me to be negative or get
stuck in that negative thing and it's
also such an instinct for me to be like
oh cool we got a problem cool we're
gonna go crush it that's positive right
thinking
I never thought too much about that but
now I'm like oh I get it so watch out
for that negativity yeah
yes sir and yeah if you're representing
on it that's this is where you can get
your stuff don't costore.com yep it's
not a it's not a placebo remember when
you were a kid and you got new sneakers
and you got to run you ran faster yes no
doubt about it this is like you get a
short Locker t-shirt all of a sudden
you're more disciplined yep well the
shirt Locker shirt that's like for us
enjoying ourselves on the path you know
so we kind of go out color we color
outside the lens every once in a while
with the shirt locker stuff they're fun
new design every month that's that's the
subscription one but you know if you're
wearing discipline equals freedom and
you choose to work out with that shirt
you know you put on that shirt the
chance of you skipping that workout go
down to zero zero it's not not possible
not possible uh so there you go
subscribe to this podcast as well
subscribe to Jocko underground subscribe
to the YouTube channel the originusa
YouTube channel the Jocko fuel YouTube
channel uh go to flipsidecanvas.com and
get something pretty hang on your wall
got a bunch of books let's get this book
Cold War Navy seal by James M Haas and
Mary Ann Koenig I forgot to mention
Marianne Koenig but she also uh helped
write the book so there you go Cold War
Navy SEAL a bunch of really interesting
stuff it's so weird
again I was talking about this with Jim
when we were offline is just like
I went to the the Seal team one
anniversary yeah a little while back
60th year anniversary
but I also went to the 30-year
anniversary and so 30 years before that
was wind Seal Team One got made oh damn
so this is all like I've been around I
you know you're around people that are
generally generationally all part of
this group yeah it's kind of wild but a
lot of those historical things I
mentioned that to them like I've known
about the the war in the Congo that's a
thing yeah and now you're sitting here
talking to Jim and he's literally worked
directly with Lieutenant Colonel Mad
Mike like that's crazy to think
about
crazy to think about so anyways check
out his book check out a bunch of books
that I've written final spin leadership
strategy and tactics Field Manual
a bunch of bunch of books we have a
leadership consultancy it's called
Echelon front if you want need help from
a leadership perspective inside your
organization go to echelonfront.com we
also have an online Training Academy
because leadership and life is not
something that you just are able to just
cruise through and know what to do you
don't none of us do that's why we made
this Training Academy online go to
extreme ownership.com come and check out
some of our free classes just you when
you take a free classroom oh I get it
these are weird skills
I was telling you know I was telling the
troops on so we got a question on the
academy the other day yeah a guy says
hey my boss is not being transparent not
telling us what's going on but it's
starting to you know be a little bit of
a problem with the team and I was like
yep hey here's what you're gonna need to
do
everyone that's on this call
so we're only doing a live webinar on
Extreme ownership.com I said everybody
that's on this call right now
if you if you and we all we all take
ownership we all subordinate our ego we
all prioritize relationships we all work
to build trust and listen to each other
that's what we're doing
and if you're doing that you are better
at relationships and Leadership than 99
of the world so when you've got your
boss that's not behaving like a good
leader
you're the one that has to use these
techniques
to help them close the gaps on their
leadership which is a powerful thing
right it's like you're trying to build a
house like Echoes over here I'm watching
you or let's say Echo you're building a
house for me
and and I go in and all of a sudden I
see like Echo doesn't have
a square to make sure that the that the
walls are square and I'm like hey bro no
it's all good I got this square right
here and you're like oh thanks I'm
actually helping you yeah it's not my
job I know you're the house Builder but
what am I supposed to do sit back and
watch my house be crooked
maybe you don't have
maybe you don't you're not good at
Plumbing
and so I go hey man let me help you with
that plumbing let me fill let me fill in
the gaps right here oh yeah your
drywall's not you're not quite that good
of a drywaller let me give you a hand so
I'm just making these little now listen
you're the leader you should be doing
this yourself and I can sit back oh this
is all messed up but guess what I gotta
live in the house yeah
so go to extreme ownership.com learn
these skills and then you can help your
leader you can help your peers you can
help your subordinates
and by the way just FYI you don't help
them by saying hey Echo you got a major
problem with your leadership no that's
not what you do because then they get
defensive you use the indirect approach
you work through it so that's what we're
doing go to extreme ownership.com we
will help you learn to lead it'll make
everything in your life better
and if you want to help service members
active and retired you want to help
their their families Gold Star Family
check out Mark Lee's mom mama Lee she's
got a charity organization and if you
want to donate or you want to get
involved go to America's Mighty Warriors
dot org and also don't forget about
Micah think
who last report
was riding a mountain lion
through the wilderness
and he was rescuing a small bear from a
tree so that's that's what you know go
to
heroesandhorses.org he's out there in
the wilderness helping veterans find
themselves
and if you want to connect with us Echo
is at Echo Charles I am at Jocko willink
we're on the various social media
platforms but just just be advised you
think those social media platforms are
there for you
they're there for your benefit they're
not
they're there for their benefit so just
be careful because they got algorithms
that are going to try and hook you up
thanks once again to Jim Haas for coming
out and sharing his experiences and
Lessons Learned and more important
thanks to Jim for all he did to support
and defend democracy around the world
and a special thanks to those who served
with him
aligned with freedom the Cubans the
belgians the Americans who fought and
continued to fight clandestine Wars to
protect
the cause of freedom
and also thank you to our police and law
enforcement firefighters paramedics EMTs
dispatchers correctional officers border
patrol Secret Service and all First
Responders thank you for fighting to
keep us safe here at home and to
everyone else out there
you're not gonna get things served to
you on a silver platter
you're not going to get the money that
you need you're not going to get the
support that you want you're not going
to get blessed with a perfect team of
people that have the perfect set of
skills you're not going to get any of
that that's the way life is
but like Jim Haws
you still have to figure it out you have
to make it happen you have to create
something
from nothing
and if you do that you too can achieve
victory
and you do that
by getting out there every day
and getting after it
and until next time this is Echo and
Jocko out